je suis heureux de vous accueillir
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
d'être parmi nous de de prendre ce temps
vous avez été nommé ministre dans le
gouvernement d'Élisabeth borne en mai
2022 vous succédez à Julien de lormandie
que nous avons auditionné
hier
et cette commission a pour objet de
comprendre pour être pertinente dans ses
recommandations comprendre non pas pour
excuser mais s'agissant de quelque chose
de complexe notamment qui reposete
politique publique qui implique
notamment quatre administration centrale
la vôtre celle de la santé celle de la
recherche et celle de la transition
écologique il est important pour nous de
comprendre là où ça coince
euh les nos auditions nous ont permis de
repérer un problème de gouvernance
notamment dans le pilotage financier
alors naturellement vous n'êtes pas
comptable de ce qui s'est passé avant
mais il est important pour nous euh
d'avoir votre votre témoignage sur ce
que vous avez perçu en prenant vos
fonctions et depuis sur la place de
cette politique publique parmi les
autres parmi les nombreuses priorités
que que sont les vôtres sur la fluidité
ou le grippage de l'interministériel sur
ce
dossier c'est important pour nous aussi
d'avoir votre regard sur le PSN que vous
avez fait
interrir vous le savez il y a une une
partie critique sur l'ambition de ce PSN
sur le sur le les écorégimes sur le
l'argent de la pack qui est dédié à
cette ambition
agroécologique et et de nous répondre en
en toute franchise en toute sincérité
sur
euh ce que la façon dont vous pensez que
ces objectifs peuvent être atteints être
atteints sachant que ça fait des années
qu'ils sont reportés et qu'on peut se
demander si les objectifs actuels on en
prend le
chemin donc je vais vous je vais vous
laisser la parole pour une intervention
liminaire d'une dizaine de minutes à la
suite de quoi le rapporteur réagira et
puis on ouvrira l'échange aux membres de
la Commission présente euh et avant cela
je vous rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée et qu'en vertu de l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
vous êtes tenu de prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et je vais donc vous demander de
lever la main droite et de dire je le
jure je le jure je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
d'abord je vourrais saluer l'initiative
qui est la vôtre au travers de cette
commission d'enquête vous l'avez bien
décrit monsieur le Président d'essayer
se comprendre de comprendre ce qui
dfonctionne reconnaissons que on na pas
atteint un certain nombre d'objectifs
vous l'avez très bien dit deuxièmement
de décrire la complexité des choses
parce que parfois on a tendance à
simplifier et à dire les les les
solutions seraient assez simple si ça a
bloqué depuis une quinzaine d'années
c'est que sans doute il a il y a des
points de grippage que vous essayez de
lever qui sont importants 3oè élément
mais on en parlera peut-être dans les
échanges de le remettre aussi dans un
contexte où au-delà de la question des
phytosanitaires on a tout tout un enjeu
de transition phytosanitaire mais aussi
tous les enjeux de transition sur le
carbone tous les enjeux de transition
des modèles économiques en particulier M
et nécessité par le dérèglement
climatique et donc je suis très heureux
d'être là devant vous mesdames et
messieurs les députés alors d'abord pour
dire que les agriculteurs évoluent
reconnaissons-le dans un contexte de
plus en plus complexe d'abord où se
conjugue et c'est un des effets de du
dérèglement climatique sans doute de
l'augmentation de la pression des
ravageurs et le retrait en corolaire
d'un certain nombre de substances
actives tout cela devant être au
rendez-vous ceci étant de la
souveraineté alimentaire la réduction
d'usage des produits phy
phyoparmaceutique pardon constitue
néanmoins une nécessité un enjeu pour
préserver à la fois les enjeux de santé
les enjeux de biodiversité les enjeux de
qualité de l'eau la transition de nos
systèmes de production est indispensable
mais elle doit se faire sans
désarmer sans désarmer notre protection
des cultures sans désarmer notre niveau
de production et notre souverain
alimentaire transition agroécologique et
souveraineté alimentaire sont
indissociables et même interdépendantes
j'ai tendance à dire à chaque fois que
faut pas opposer l'un à l'autre et que
c'est l'un et l'autre qui doivent se
conjuguer dans cette affaire c'est dans
ce casadre que le gouvernement a fait de
la baisse de l'utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques une priorité le
plan écito de plus matérialise les
engagements pris en ce sens etcofito
répond aussi à une obligation européenne
fixée par la une directive européenne de
2009 instaurant un cadre d'action
communautaire pour parvenir à une
utilisation des pesticides compatibles
avec le développement durable dit
directive Sud en cours de révision mais
on ena parlera peut-être avec le
règlement dit sûr l'actuel plan écopyo
de plus et la 3ème génération de plans
écofyo comportant un objectif de
réduction des usages issu du Grenel de
l'environnement le premier plan affirmé
en 2008 une volonté vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président de réduire l'usage
des produits phytopharmaceutiques
agricoles de 50 % dans un délai de 10
ans si possible à horizon
2018 en 2015 devant la faiblesse des
résultats un plan écopyo 2 a été défini
l'objectif de - 50 % a alors été
repoussé en 2025 avec un objectif
intermédiaire de - 25 à horizon 2020
cela démontre la complexité de
l'exercice et les difficultés qui se
font jour dès qu'il s'agit non plus de
fixer un objectif théorique mais de les
décliner de manière opérationnelle et
concrète en responsabilité si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi en tenant compte des
enjeux de santé publique des enjeux
environnementaux des enjeux économiques
pour un secteur comme vous le savez
stratégique pour le pays et c'est me
semble-t ce qu'on pu également
appréhender les gouvernements et les
majorités qui se sont succédés depuis
2008 l'échec avait donc été constaté en
2016 sur les objectifs fixés lors du
Grenel de l'environnement de 2008 en
effet entre 2009 et 2013 le NODU
principal indicateur pour mesurer la
quantité des pesticides utilisés a
augmenté de 16 % entre 2013 et 2018 le
NODU a continué d'augmenter de 2 %. ce
sont d'ailleurs je le dis au passage C
10 dernières années d'échec qui ont été
sanctionnés par le tribunal
administratif de Paris dans un jugement
dont a pris le gouvernement comme vous
le savez en 2018 lors de la préparation
du plan écito 2 plus le gouvernement a
cherché à tirer les conséquences de
l'échec des plans précédent ce plan a
alors apporté une nouvelle impulsion
pour atteindre l'objectif de réduire les
usages de produits
phytopharmaceutiques d'ici 2025 de - 50
% et de laisser le baisser pour d'autres
usages sans laisser les agriculteurs
sans solution c'est bien l'objectif que
nous partageons même si notre objectif
global de réduction n'est pas encore
atteint autant autant le dire la France
je crois est pleinement engagée dans une
dynamique de réduction de l'utilisation
des produits phyos depuis 2017 pour la
première fois c'est quand même une
tendance qu'il faut regarder les
quantités baissent grâce aux différentes
actions envisagées alors est-ce que
c'est l'effet de sédimentation ou c'est
un effet
d'accélération mais en tout cas c'est un
un élément qui existe substitution
encadrement des usages financement de
matériel agricole depuis 5 ans pour la
première fois depuis 15 ans donc depuis
qui est apparu cet objectif la quantité
de pesticides vendu et consommé en
France baisse à la fois en quantité
vendu et en
dangerosité des produits utilisés et les
deux critères me paraissent intéressants
grâce à écofito 2 plus pour la première
fois depuis 2010 notre action commence à
se traduire par une baisse de 20 % des
volumes de produits vendus baisses
particulièrement marqué sur les produits
considérés comme les plus dangereux mais
je vousai signalé aussi et la baisse je
l'ai dit à plusieurs reprises sur le
glyphosate le plan écophyo de plus a
donc produit des résultats concrets les
données de vente disponibles pour 2022
confirment comme vous le savez la baisse
des quantités de substances actives
rendu avec 43000 tonnes en 2022 elle
baisse de 20 % par rapport à la moyenne
2015- 2017 de même les indicateurs de
suivi du plan écopyo NODU marqu une
diminution marquée historique de l'usage
des produits phytopharmaceutiques si
commencez à concrétiser les actions
engagées depuis 2017 mais le net
intellectuel me fait penser que c'est
sans doute en partie le produit des
actions qui ont été engagées depuis 2008
mais qui trouvent là seulement peut-être
leur traduction c'est la difficulté de
la transition et du temps qu'il faut
parfois la vente des produits les plus
préoccupants les cmr1 comme vous le
savez a baissé de 93 % depuis 2016 et
puis pour ne citer que cet exemple
l'utilisation du glyphosate a réduit
fortement par rapport à la période de
référence précédente qui était 2015 2017
puisqu'elle a été réduite de 27 %. en
outre et au-delà du plan écofitodo
lui-même le gouvernement a pris
plusieurs actions je crois assez fortes
pour inciter à accompagné à la baisse
d'usage des produits
phytopharmaceutiques dans les
différentes utilisations un programme
prioritaire de recherche doté de 30
millions d'euros destiné à accroîre la
mobilisation des scientifiques pour
développer des solutions alternatives
nous en reparlerons peut-être le plan de
relance pour accompagner les
agriculteurs
notamment sur le développement des
agroéquipements grand un grand un des
grands enjeux de la réduction des
produits phyosanitaires c'est la
massification d'équipements qui permett
de réduire leurs usages mais qui
permettent aussi de d'assumer
globalement la transition agroécologique
je vais signalé aussi France 2030 4
milliards d'euros dont 1,2 milliards
pour l'agriculture le reste étant plutôt
ventilé sur l'aspect alimentaire et qui
sont investis et seront investis doivent
permettre de financer de solutions
durables et innovantes je pense aux
outils de biocontrôle la sélection
variétale la la robotique et le
numérique je le dis souvent c'est un des
éléments de la réponse ça n'est pas
toute la réponse tout ne passe pas par
la technique ou la science ou la
robotique mais enfin c'est des éléments
qui combiner les uns avec les autres
peuvent permettre de répondre et puis un
plan de développement de l'agriculture
biologique qui conduit à augmenter de
plus de 50 % la surface en Bur de 2015 à
2021 2,78 million d'hectares contre 1,3
million en 2015 alors je n'ignore pas ce
qu'est la situation ce n'est pas l'objet
de votre commission d'enquête de la
filière bio mais en tout cas la
trajectoire que nous avons cherché qu'il
faut maintenir est une trajectoire qui
me paraît importante à souligner enfin
les actions d'amplification se
poursuivent et se renforcent en matière
d'anticipation et d'accompagnement c'est
tout l'objectif de la stratégie ecofito
2030 ou 2030 dont la proposition a été
présentée lors du comité d'orientation
stratégique du 30 octobre dernier qui
s'inscrit dans l'ensemble des chantiers
qui accompagnent aujourd'hui la
transition de notre modèle agcole je
crois que cette réunion a permis de
souligner l'ensemble des parties
prenantes ont souligné le sérieux du
travail et la perspective dans lequelle
ils s'inscrivaient ce plan Profito 2030
r point à une triple ambition préserver
la santé publique et celle de
l'environnement dans une logique une
seule santé maintenir un haut niveau de
protection des cultures qui est un enjeu
majeur de sécurité alimentaire soutenir
les performances économiques et
environnementales des exploitations
surtout le gouvernement a voulu proposer
une nouvelle approche et une nouvelle
méthode que beaucoup appelaient de leur
vœux pour mieux se préparer au potentiel
retrait de certaines substances actives
et à l'accélération du développement des
des solutions alternative qu'ell soit
chimique ou non chimique enfin la
reconception des systèmes agricoles et
alimentaires en pensant à l'échelle de
l' de la chaîne de valeur des filières
et c'est une méthode qui vient répondre
à une évidence qui n'est pas qu'une
évidence me semble-t-il au regard des
enjeux de santé ou d'environnement mais
aussi pour le monde
agricole car les agriculteurs eux-mêmes
ne peuvent pas et ne veulent pas vivre
de dérogation en dérogation je dis
souvent que les interdictions ne
produisent pas les solutions mais que
les dérogations n'invitent pas forcément
non plus à chercher les solutions que la
dérogation est un outil et permet de
répondre à des enjeux immédiats et
d'urgence sanitair sur les cultures mais
qu'en même temps il faut qu'on on donne
des perspectives plus long terme et de
dérogation parfois en interdiction qui
sont parfois peu ou mal planifié c'est
un exercice exigeant qui est parfois
exigeant et compris avec la profession
de lucidité sur ce qu'est le devenir des
molécules ce qui est le risque de
retrait de cette molécule et de le faire
dans une perspective de moyen et long
terme nous avions donc besoin de
construire réellement des trajectoires
partagées y compris avec la profession
dans cette logique la reconception que
j'évoqué doit s'appuyer sur la mise au
point d'Alternativ aux méthodes
existantes y compris des alternatives
non chimiques sur une approche
Interfilière et sur différentes
la parcelle l'exploitation agricole le
territoire ou la région et comme l'a dit
la première ministre au salon de
l'agriculture anticiper innover
accompagné sur les trois piliers de
l'action que nous entendons conduire
cela passe par une importance accrue de
l'agronomie de manière à développer des
solutions alternatives et sortir d'une
logique prépondérante de substitution
d'une substance active par une autre ou
seulement d'une substance active par une
autre au fur et à mesure des
interdiction on voit bien tous les
effets de report qu'ont eu les
interdictions successives et à la fin
des impasses cette approche nécessite
l'engagement des représentants
professionnels pour ne plus subir des
interdictions non anticipées le recours
à la recherche et l'innovation pour
trouver des alternatives est un élément
important je le disais sélection
variétale du contrôle afin de faire
évoluer les pratiques agricoles
constituent un axe fort de notre action
c'est si on veut avancer sur ce sujet la
nécessité c'est de reconcevoir les
modèles reconcevoir la façon dont les
cette trajectoire et cette volonté de
protéger les culture et et penser et ça
c'est un élément important et donc c'est
le sens du travail que nous avons lancé
nous mobiliser collectivement avec les
instituts techniques et les
interpressions pour ne plus être dans
une gestion que je moi vous me demandiez
monsieur le Président ce que j'avais
constaté j'avais le sentiment qu'on géit
au coup par coup un peu qu'à chaque fois
on poussait devant nous les difficultés
je fais de GRF à personne c'est pas
l'objet de ce genre de de travail en
commun mais il me semble que là on
essaie de regarder plutôt dans
trajectoire long terme de de ne pas
fonctionner dans des logiques de silo
mais mobiliser l'ensemble des Mons de la
chaîne le monde agricole les Institutes
de recherche les agences publiques comme
l'an les acteurs privés porteurs
d'innovation pour mieux anticiper et
développer des solutions combinat je le
répète chimique ou non chimique
l'objectif de notre travail collectif
est d'élargir l'éventail des solutions
disponibles pour éviter que les
agriculteurs ne se retrouvent sans
solution les involutions à conduire
constituent un changement fondamental
nécessite donc un travail sur le long
terme pour le mener à bien il nous faut
regarder la réalité de la situation
phytosanitaire pour s'y préparer du
mieux possible en toute transparence et
en confiance dans le débat et non dans
l'injonction F on a eu des débats y
compris quand on a présenté un certain
nombre de molécules sur lesquelles il
fallait s'interroger y compris dans la
reconception de modèle y compris dans
les al alternative en disant mais c'est
toutes ces molécules vous voulez les
interdire le sujet c'est pas ça c'est
que on a des réautorisations des
réhomologations des autorisations de
mise sur le marché qui vont venir sur la
table on voit bien qu'on a des effets de
report sur un certain nombre de
molécules on s'est dit qu'il valait
mieux regarder l'ensemble de classes de
molécules y compris par classe d'usage
les herbicide d'un côté et cetera pour
faire en sorte qu'on regarde lucidement
sans sans sans être dans l'injonction de
l'interdiction mais lucidement comment
trouver dès à présent des alternatives
je dis au passage que c'est un élément
important avant de conclure de nouveaux
moyens additionnels et conséquents en
complément ce dé déjà alloué via la
redevance fameuse redevance pour les
pollutions diffuses sont spécifiquement
alloué par l'État pour la mise en œuvre
de la stratégie écofito 2030 je rappelle
que RPD c'est environ 180 millions
d'euros que ce qui est identifiable dans
la logique de
transition et plutôt à hauteur de 70
millions réparti entre les choses qui
sont dédié au niveau national et puis ce
qui est dédié aux agences de l'eau pour
mener leurs propres actions mais on a
décidé de mettre des moyens
supplémentaires qui sont des moyens à la
main du ministère issus du chanté de
planification écologique et quand je
vous dis les échells c'est 250 millions
d'euros qui sont proposés dans projet le
mois de finance 2024 dont une part
importante financera des plin d'action
spécifiques des filières sur les usages
de produits phytopharmaceutiques
identifiés comme critiques il faut qu'on
prenne aussi dans l'ordre chronologique
c'està-dire on voit bien qu'il y a des
sujets sur lequels il y aura des
impasses également prévu une aide à
l'investissement pour les matériels qui
viendra prolonger au fond ce qui a
été émergé si je peux dire dans le
casadre de France relance
une aide à investissement pour des
matériels nécessaires à la transition
agroécologique et le financement de
projets territorialis territorialisés
s'ajoutera une allocation de crédit
France 2030 dédié à ecofito 2030 dont le
montant sera arbitré très prochainement
par la première ministre voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Rapporteur constatant la situation
d'échec dans laquelle nous sommes et que
vous avez évoqué on essaie d'avoir une
stratégie qui une stratégie plutôt de
moyen long terme avec des moyens qui
soient dédiés en essayant d'embarquer
l'ensemble de la filière alors je je dis
souvent ça je sais que le président
aussi très attaché il s qu'il faut qu'on
embarque tout le monde dans la filière
c'est l'amont et laav parce que cette
affaire de réduction des phyos c'est une
affaire de tout le monde ça peut pas
être une affaire où on fait porter
uniquement la charge et la pression la
difficulté les impasses sur le monde
agricole il faut que tout le monde dans
la chaîne y compris la chaîne de valeur
se sente saisi de la question c'est long
mais il me semble qu'en plus sans être
inutilement positif on a une trajectoire
qui commence à se dessiner de réduction
des produits phytosanitaires et il faut
aussi le saluer parce que il y a quelque
chose je le dis au passage parfois
désespérant dans le monde agricole avec
le sentiment que jamais assz jamais
comme il faut et jamais la trajectoire
qu'il faudrait or on a une trajectoire
qui commence à se dessiner c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire
merci merci monsieur le ministre pour la
concision la la densité de ces propos
liminires monsieur le rapporteur je vous
laisse
réagir merci monsieur le ministre pour
la force de votre propos à
l'instant le président l'a dit nous nous
envisageons dès le départ nousons
envisager cette commission comme une
contribution positive au débat public et
je voulais vous le dire d'emblé le plan
éofuto 2030 tel qu'il apparaît nous
paraît une base de travail intéressante
nous nous félicitons que par une
interpellation que je m'étais permis de
faire à Matignon c'était on avait été
étonné de la publication d'un document
avant les résultats de la commission
d'enquête et on a eu
l'assurance par une réponse de la
première ministre que à la fois les
travaux de la commission d'enquête et
l'évolution des débats autour de la du
règlement sûr du règlement sûr euh ce
serait évidemment prise en compte pour
un atterrissage début 2024 et on est pas
15 jours prprès ou un mois après quoi
donc effectivement on ne travaille pas
pour rien et je sais votre attachement
historique au Parlement et je nous
espérons pas nous en parlions encore
hier soir que que nos propositions vous
aident éclaire en tout cas les les choix
que vous aurez à faire en
responsabilité je je me permets on prend
le temps c'est un moment important pour
nous parce que hasard du calendrier dans
vos réponses et vos agendas on a
aujourd'hui le ministre en
responsabilité aujourd'hui et on va
avoir dans 1 heure3 de à peu près
Stéphane Lefol qui a été le ministre et
on a pris les deux bornes on a pris 10
ans on n pas remonté à Jean-Louis borlau
he on a pris on a pris 10 ans 10 ans
c'est le rapport de l'Inserm de 2013
qu'on forait en 2021 sur les alertes
sanitaires c'est entre nous un petit peu
aussi le rapport que que j'avais rendu
au Premier ministre sur la la réforme
des cofuto qui a inspiré cofuto 2 mais
c'est surtout le rapport de linerm et et
donc on a les deux ministres qui qui
bornent cette période que nous examinons
donc c'est une
matinée très intéressante pour nous je
me permets parce que vous êtes le
Ministre en charge simplement le Premier
ministre en responsabilité de de vous
confier pour la qualité de notre
dialogue un peu ce que va être le récit
de notre de notre de notre rapport t
qu' ah d'accord je crois faut pardonal
pour après
euh pardon pardon euh je vrais juste
vous redire peut-être pour la clarté de
l'échange qu'on va avoir dans la
tranquillité on a le temps et
commissaires sont sont nombreux moi je
je m'en réjouis on va avoir un beau
dialogue euh en vérité euh on va
répondre à trois question euh est-ce
est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut réduire les
phitos à 50 % et peut-être même à zéro à
l'horizon 2050 plus loin et cetera nous
allons répondre OUI au vu de l'état de
la science tel que nous l'avons mobilisé
tout l'été où au mois de juillet on a on
a reçu à peu près t tous les tes les
autorités scientifiques sur le sujets on
est absolument convaincu que cette
réduction est est indispensable pour
pour toutes les raisons que nous
connaissons
de la deuxème question c'est est-ce
qu'elle est techniquement possible on a
à peu près des assurances sur - 30 % sur
50 % on commence à changer les systèmes
et au-delà c'est une véritable
révolution des des systèmes donc on va
on va répondre que voilà on va essayer
d'être cohérent avec oui il y a besoin
de les réduire mais on sait ce que ça VE
en cohérence bon techniquement c'est
possible est-ce que c'est compatible et
là je vis j'insiste sur ce point parce
qu'il est toujours ceux qui doutent ou
qui veulent faire douter sur cette
urgente nécessité de baisser les phyos
argumentent toujours sur la souveraineté
alimentaire et sur le climat qui sont
deux autres grandes ambitions de la
nation il nous semble que nous
répondrons qu'il est possible de
conilier réduction de la l'usage de la
phytopharmacie atténuation et adaptation
au changement climatique et d'autre part
garantie de notre souveraineté
alimentaire voilà donc c'est voici les
les questions auxquelles nous allons
répondre dans le rapport avec un plan ça
sera pas sera pas une surprise qui
avec C chapitres importants après un
état de la science on explorera le
régime
d'autorisation on adoptera on examinera
le continuum recherche développement
accompagnement des agriculteurs on
interrogera les politiques publiques PAC
PSN on interrogera le poids du marché le
levier du marché tant
interne français européens et les
relations
internationales et puis on s'intéressera
pour finir au pilotage de de ce plan qui
qu' on a sacrément manqué depuis depuis
des années je vrais vous dire en
préambule je prends le temps parce que
c'est c'est je pense que c'est ces
propos comme les vôtres sont importants
pour poser les termes du débat que nous
reprocherons à aucun ministre à
l'instanté les résultats qui sont
publiés d'ailleurs très tardivement hein
pour Conn les résultat de la de l'impact
d'une année il faut attendre un an 1 an
et demi enfin c'est c'est toujours très
long c'est c'est compliqué et cetera
c'est c'est c'est un des défauts du du
pilotage de ce plan c'est qu'on a pas de
de réponse assez rapide mais en tout cas
on fera reproche à aucun ministre
d'avoir eu des mauvais résultats pendant
son sa période parce qu'on est assez
conscient que s'il a des bons résultats
et vous avez eu l'honnêteté de le dire
ça peut être grâce aux efforts qui
précédit et s'il a des mauvais résultats
idem donc on fera pas de procès par
contre on va examiner pour chaque
ministre qu'on a fait Julien Normandie
hier particulièrement les décisions
qu'il a pris et ce sur quoi il a pesé
quand il était au responsabilités donc
l'obligation de moyens plus que la
nature des résultats on le dit par
honnêteté intellectuelle pas de mauvais
procès CELI que en 2018 a eu un pic
parce que on a annoncé une augmentation
de la RPD c'est pas de sa faute bon
voilà c'est pas voilà donc on saura
distinguer ça je vis tout de suite sans
ouvrir le débat parce que je pense qu'il
serait 20 vous dire
que on reste réservé sur sur la baisse
de - 20 % que vous annoncez quand on
regarde les chiffres dans leur totalité
si on les regarde sur des grandes
séquences et qu'on évite les effets des
moyennes triénales comparé avec des
effets de bord et cetera si on regarde
sur la longue durée depuis depuis
finalement le Grenel de l'environnement
en QSA on est à quelques pourcent de
variation à peine enfin ça pas ça va pas
bouger en ODU surtout en ODU en QSA une
légère baisse mais en ODU on n pas bougé
quoion chacun de ces critères est
criticable on va pas faire lmentaire il
y a des études européennes qui montrent
que la France a plutôt ces dernières
années par rapport à d'autres pays qui
ont plutôt décru donc ce qu'on va faire
et je le dis d'emblé à pas se perdre
dans ces dans dans ces dans ces
controverses qui seraient peut-être
veaines mais nous ferons état avec
objectivité dans dans la première partie
du rapport de l'ensemble des données
disponibles et nous nous noterons que il
y a pas lieu de sauter de joie et de
dire que tout va bien qu' suffit de
continuer comme ça hein c'est voilà
globalement on n'a pas atteint nos
objectifs on ne cesse de reporter les
échéances donc on n'ouvre pas la
controverse mais quand Chr Béchu vous
annoncz cette baisse de 20 % nous on a
des on dispose de données et d'autres
données qui qui tempèrent simplement
cette nouvelle et nous serions les
premiers à nous réjouir si c'était le
cas mais nous allons simplement les
modérer en prenant du temps long et en
relativisant certaines données notamment
celle du NODU qui est malheureusement
constante sur 80 millions de nou depuis
depuis depuis plus de 10 ans maintenant
qui a quasiment pas bougé al on sait
que rentr dans ces débat mais on va pas
être dans le débat il nous semble pour
maintenant rentrer dans le visce du
sujet que dans ce de vos responsabilités
sur le plan
écofyo il y a trois trois moments
importants en ce qui concerne votre
mandat depuis
2022 le premier c'est le PSN donc c'est
la politique publique européenne
déclinée en France et ses incidences sur
l'émergence au nom d'une véritable
agroécologie la deuxième élément
important c'est la construction du plan
écyo 2030 c'est c'est c'est un temps
long forcément donc voilà on va vous
interroger et et la troisième élément
c'est et vous êtes je le dis sans ironie
un petit peu à l'origine de cette
commission d'enquête en tout cas vous
l'avez très fortement motivé c'est votre
déclaration au congrès de la FNSEA le 30
mars de cette année où vous j'ai
retrouvé la citation euh donc je vouis
vous remercier pour être un peu à
l'origine de cette commission d'enquête
vous dites devant le congrès de la FNSEA
je viens je viens de demander à l'an une
réévaluation de sa décision sur le Esmé
la clore parce que cette décision n'est
pas liignée sur le calendrier européen
qu'elle tombe sans alternative crédiible
autrement dit on a vu là une menace qui
faisait écho à des travaux des sénateurs
euh globalement de de certains courants
politiques et de et de manifestations
syndicales très affirmé qui remettaient
en cause le régime d'autorisation tel
qu'adopté dans la loi de 2014 j'ai eu
l'occasion dans l'émicycle de vous
interroger et ça sera pr ma première
question monsieur le ministre elle est
cruciale dans dans dans cette audition
est-ce que vous êtes partisan ou non
d'une remise en cause du régime
d'autorisation tel qu'il a été abordé
dans adopté dans le code de la santé
publique dans la loi de 2014
merci je vais d'abord répondre à cette
question là puis je vis dire deux trois
éléments si vous me permettez Monsieur
le monsieur le
rapporteur il n pas de coutume chez moi
pour les gens qui me connaissent de
menacé qui que ce soit c'est pas ma
nature c'est pas mon tempérament c'est
pas mon histoire donc c'est pas une
question de
menace vous aurez remarqué que jamais je
n'ai remis en cause que je pense que
c'est un principe qu'il faut poser les
évaluations des agences de sécurité
sanitaire jamais y compris dans cet
épisodelà vous m'avez vu dire on a un
problème est-ce que ils ont bien raison
est-ce que euh parce que je pense que si
on rentre dans ce chemin-là euh de même
pour l'fsa d'ailleurs je pense que si on
rentre dans ce chemin-là on prend un
risque énorme c'est celui qu'à chaque
fois on vient de relativiser les fait
scientifique au gré de ce que sont nos
croyances ou nos croyances parfois c'est
de la croyance parfois en tout cas c'est
nos convictions j'ai des convictions
vous avez des convictions nous avons
tous des convictions et je pense qu'il
faut faire attention à toujours essayer
d'étaayer nos choses sur ce sujet
j'avais dit à l'époque que je considère
effectivement que dans un objectif que
pour le coup je je compte bien tenir qui
est celui qu'on ne vienne pas créer de
la distorsion en France vis-à-vis des
autres pays européens je pense que ces
sujets là la commission d'enquête ici a
sa légitimité parce que nous avons une
trajectoire à tenir y compris au niveau
européen mais je considère que se délier
totalement de ce que sont les réalités
européennes dans les calendriers serait
une erreur c'est pour ça que j'ai eu
cette expression et à la question que
vous posez je réponds non il n'est pas
dans mes intentions je ne n'ai même pas
ni pensé ni à rien pensé parce que je
pense que le sujet n'est pas là je pense
que c'est le sujet d'ailleurs tout
l'objectif a été d'embarquer l'an s y
compris dans les sujets des
alternatives l'an produit des avis sur
les autor autorisations de mise en
marché j'ajoute que d'ailleurs sur ce
cette molécule c'est à la suite d'une
demande et d'une saisine du ministère de
l'Agriculture donc on peut pas nous
faire Gief au fond de ne pas avoir
interrogé l'aness à l'époque sur ce sur
ce sujet là je crois que c'était mon
prédécesseur en revanche donc on a
besoin d'embarquer toutes les structures
et l' est un des acteurs clés à la fois
pour dire ce qu'est la molécule ce que
sont ces risques et en même temps ce que
sont les alternatives pour essayer de
construire avec eux des alternatives de
réduction mais je trouve que poser le
principe en disant nous avons une
difficulté qui peut être une difficulté
de calendrier une difficulté de quelles
sont les voies les moyens des
alternatives en disant je change le
problème en
disant je remets en cause ce qui a été
les attendus d' décision à l'époque
politique c'était sous c'était sous
Stéphane Lefol serait une erreur et je
le fais parfois contre l'AVE d'un
certain nombre de professionnels qui
penseraient que ça serait la bonne
solution je crois pas que ça soit la
bonne solution parce que de toute façon
la trajectoire de réduction elle est
nécessaire et donc ça serait une erreur
donc je suis très vous le savez
d'ailleurs monsieur le rapporteur je
suis très clair là-dessus ce n'est pas
mon intention parce que je ne pense que
c'est c'est inopérant c'est un mauvais
débat c'est un mauvais procès et en même
temps il faut qu'on embarque tout le
monde quand même chacun doit se sentir
responsable de la trajectoire qu'on a
qu'on doit qu'on doit mener si vous me
permettez de dire trois mots sur le
rebond que vous disiez est-ce qu'il faut
réduire les phito la réponse est oui
parce que vous avez dit ça va être un
peu ça notre trame j'en suis j'en suis
complètement d'accord alors réduire vous
avez raison de dire 20 % ou 30 % c'est
une étape ça c'est notamment par le
matériel par les pratiques on doit y
arriver dès qu'on arrive à 150 on est
sur la reconception des modèles donc ça
c'est toutes les fermes de référence les
structures avec les filières les
instituts techniques l'INRE enfin bon là
on a quelque chose de beaucoup plus
solide est-ce qu'on peut dire que à 2050
on peut se passer totalement de phyo
d'abord je vrais pardon je peut-être
choquer certains ici ça serait donc
l'agriculture serait le seul secteur
d'activité qui qui ne pourrait pas
utiliser de produit
de produit de nature chimique parce que
je veux dire il y a pas une un secteur
d'activité de nature humaine de nature
industrielle qui n'utilise pas des
produits chimiques donc j'interroge
quand même la question de dire le zéro
absolu comme horizon comme injonction
vous avez pas dit injonction vous mais
vous avez interrogé moi je vous dis non
mais je vous dis juste je trouve que
c'est curieux qu'on fasse appliquer à
l'agriculture ce qu'on demande pas au
produits pharmaceutique dont on se soig
qui sont des produits chimiques qu'on
demande pas à la plasturgie qu'on ne
demande pas semble qu'il y a quelque
chose quand même le zéro absolu me
paraît un horizon compliqué je le dis
d'autant plus qu'il faut quand même
qu'on se préserve et on le voit dans un
certain nombre d'impasse qu'on produit
on peut avoir des accidents climatiques
qui fassent que certaines années on on a
un besoin de recours aux usages des
produits phyos pour juste pas perdre
toutes les récoltes je le dis aussi
simplement que ça est-ce que c'est
techniquement possible j'ai répondu oui
je pense que c'est techniquement
possible c'est plutôt du combinatoire
qu'un seule solution mais vous le savez
mieux que moi et vous le savez aussi
bien que moi donc et est-ce que alors
vous m'aveait toujours trouvé sur le
chemin de dire ne disons pas on peut pas
faire la la souveraineté alimentaire si
jamais on réduit les phyos on peut faire
la souveraineté alimentaire en réduisant
les phito sous la réserve que on ne
mette pas les gens face à des impasses
et qu'on leur dise pas vous avez une
alternative quand ils n'en ont pas il y
a des ici dans cette salle des gens qui
connaissent le sujet je suis désolé de
dire que nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
d'alternative qui ne soit pas trop
impactante de rendement sur la betterave
et j'ai maintenu quand même les
positions nous n'avons pas d'alternative
aujourd'hui crédiible sur la sererise
sans doute avons-nous pris trop de
retard tard sur ces sujets là et ça pose
cette question là de dire on sait que
cette molécule là quand je vois que
parfois on me re réclame le dimétoat et
le faus m qui ont été interdit il y a
plus d'une dizaine d'années je me dis
que y compris intellectuellement et nous
comme responsable public on n pas fait
le chemin qu'il fallait pour dire on va
trouver des solutions à ces sujets là
donc voilà pour ces éléments là que je
voulais vous dire et sur les chiffres
bon ça ser fera partie manifestement et
c'est au bon sens du terme pour moi de
la controverse après tout les éléments
qu'on vous donne c'est c'est des
éléments de comparaison avec les
chiffres qui sont ceux qui sont utilisés
à chaque séquence triénale pour juger ou
pas de l'efficacité mais en tout cas on
regardera avec attention ce que vous
pourrait dire sur le le challenge que
vous faites sur les NODU et la façon
dont on les évalue mais il me semble
qu'en tout cas nous c'est la même façon
de les quantifier dans les périodes qui
sont qui sont analysé donc quand je dis
in 20 % j'ai tendance à me fier à ce que
disent les gens depuis 15 ans sur ces
sujets là y compris à l'époque on disait
ça réduit pas mais mais ça ça ça vaudra
le coup sans doute d'en reparler
merci monsieur le ministre je je je vais
pousser encore sur la question de de
l'autorisation c'est sacrément important
et encore une fois on y a consacré
beaucoup beaucoup de temps deux
auditions avec l'fsa deux auditions avec
l'an centré sur cette question du du
régime d'autorisation donc je note à cet
instant que très clairement le
gouvernement je pense qu'on peut dire le
gouvernement à travers vous he Clement
si si c'est pas le ministre de la Santé
qui va remettre en cause ni celui de
l'écologie la loi de 2014 c'est peu
probable on le on leur posera la
question mais c'est peu probable le
ministre de l'riculture donc le
gouvernement ne remet pas en cause le
régime d'autorisation c'est l qui
prendra les décisions et on va se
limiter aux dérogations alors vous
appelez et je vrais qu'on on aille
jusqu'au bout pour lever l'ambigué vous
dites pas de pas d'interdiction sans
solution nous constatons et il fautut il
faut admettre quandme en rigueur
intellectuelle il y a une contradiction
c'est que les interdictions sont apparu
vous avez cité le cas de la serise di
mtoat vous avez vous avez vous savez
qu'on a eu des interdictions sans
solution et que globalement c'est quand
même le volet réglementaire qui a été le
plus efficace l'ensemble de la recherche
et du développement a finalement eu peu
d'incidence c'est l'analyse qu'on fait
c'est le volet réglementaire c'est le
retrait des molécules avec parfois des
effets de bord sur les quantités
utilisées hein pour remplir remplacer
une molécule parfois faut utiliser deux
fois plus d'une autre et cetera donc
tout la bataille des chiffres qui peut
être son ambivalence mais en tout
cas je vrais qu'on clarifie le fait que
quand vous dites pas d'interdiction sans
solution c'est une invitation à trouver
des solutions avant les interdictions
mais pas une remise en cause des
interdictions si on pe avoir une réponse
courte c'est une réponse de
clarification je je pensais avoir été
clair mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
chercher les solutions et anticiper les
solutions parce que vous dites les
interdictions ont produit leur
efficacité iles ont produit leur
efficacité par nature une fois qu'une
molécule est interdite pardon de le dire
elle n'est plus utilisée bon très bien
euh enfin ça a produit des effets pour
le coup en terme de souveraineté quand
ça a été sans solution ça c'est c'est
vrai c'est avéré pour le coup et c'est
et je ne dis pas ça pour dire faut pas
procéder à des interdictions je dis ça
juste parce que ce sont les faits en
fait qui s'imposent à nous et c'est pour
ça qu'on a changé notre stratégie sur
écopyo 2030 en disant il y a des
molécules sur lesqueles on sait qu'il y
aura des interrogations peut-être des
réductions d'usage et donc cherchons dès
à présent les solutions pour ne pas nous
trouver dans une solution non pas de
remise en cause d'interdiction mais
d'interdiction sans
solution s'agit d'un des principaux
moteurs de la commission d'enquête elle
a a été utile cette clarification est
totalement faite aujourd'hui c'est une
invitation urgente à trouver de vraies
solutions pour garantir notre
souveraineté alimentaire et quand il y
aura des interdictions que nous que le
gouvernement ne remettra pas en cause
donc si une loi arrivait ferme France du
Sénat le gouvernement donnera unité
favorable au contenu qu'elle propose
c'est vraiment de nature à nous rassurer
c'est un élément politique majeur que
nous affirmons aujourd'hui si ferme
France arrive au calendrier par un
groupe ou l'autre il n'aura pas le
soutien du gouvernement c'est un élément
de rassurance très important que nous
avons ce matin mais merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors vous parlez
d'harmonisation européenne vous avez 120
jours comme comme vous pouvez sortir 120
jours je crois c'est ça de dérogation
pour réaligner sur une décision
européenne personne ne le conteste ça
serait 150 ça serait 200 c'est la
question est pas là mais en tout cas on
peut avoir des décalages réels au-delà
d'une saison he de de traitement he le
temps de se retourner de de s'adapter on
peut avoir de vrais décalage avec
l'Union européenne et nousous sommes
interrogés avec le président avec les
commissaires c'est un peu le boulot
aussi d' mission d'enquête c'est pas
seulement de porter le fer c'est aussi
d'avoir une vision prospective et un peu
détacher des intérêts à court terme et
de l'exécutif c'est de se dire mais
après tout une harmonisation totale à
l'échelle européenne qui bien sûr
tiendrait compte des zonages
pédoclimatiques on va pas faire les
mêmes règlements pour la Lituanie et
pour le Portugal on est d'accord he mais
une politique européenne unifiée farait
pas dire qu' qu'elle solliciterait pas
les savoirs d'agence national mais plus
unifié sur les sur les molécules et les
produits
non seulement sur l'évaluation du risque
mais sur la gestion du risque est-ce que
finalement pour le grand Européen que
vous êtes au nom de la formation
politique qui est la votre c'est pas un
nos raisons
souhaitable absolument alors d'abord
rappele quand même que les les les les
décisions nationales ne s'appliquent pas
sur les substances actives que ça c'est
au niveau européen mais je pense y
compris dans la réglementation sûre que
le sujet principal est un sujet de
niveau
européen on ne peut pas dans un espace
économique
unique il y a les closuses miroirs les
fermetures de frontières avec les
Allemands et les Espagnols c'est ça
n'existe pas en
fait deuxième élément je pense que si on
veut activer des cross miroirs à
l'extérieur de nos frontières il faut
que nous parlions d'une seule voix et
que donc j'aille pas voir mes petits
collègues et grands collègues c'est pas
des questions de taille mais tous mes
collègues européens en leur disant nous
on a produit une interdiction chez nous
en France de de mise sur le marché ou
des restrictions de cette nature faut
faire pareil en close mir européenne
parce qu'il on a besoin d'harmonisation
européenne donc c'est valable sur les
autorisations de vous avez raison raison
je pense qu'il faut alors ce qui se fait
déjà c'est ce qui s'est fait d'ailleurs
pardon sur le glyphosate c'est faut
faire faut faire un travail de
l'ensemble des agences et d'ailleurs
souvent sur un certain nombre d'analyses
il y a telle ou telle agence dans tel ou
tel pays qui qui est chargé de faire une
évaluation sur tel ou tel produit he
c'est c'est comme ça que ça seraé
pararti mais je pense qu'on a besoin de
le mettre au niveau européen troisème
élément sur les processus d'autorisation
de mise sur le marché de nouvelles
molécules d'ailleurs enfin usage
chimique ou non chimique he y compris
sur le biocontrôle on peut pas avoir
autant de temporalité différent d'un
payis à l'autre et après tout si c'est
fait dans si c'est fait en Allemagne ou
si c'est fait en France je ne vois pas
pourquoi ça ne viendrait pas assez
rapidement s'imposer aux autres pays
européens parce qu'après tout c'est des
agences qui sont reconnus je crois qu'on
peut dire quand même qu'on a un système
d'agence au niveau national comme au
niveau européen qui est reconnu au
niveau mondial commetant de qualité donc
je plus on le mettra au niveau européen
monsieur sera y compris sur la recherche
des alternatives en cela le règlement
sûr est plutôt porteur d'une forme
d'harmonisation par la nature même de de
l'instrument juridique le règlement il
apporte il tranche pas sur la question
molécule et produit j'hui il tranche pas
sur un sble de sujets mais il est il a
une vertu quand même d'harmonisation sur
sur unensble de points et notamment sur
les obligations faites aux États-membres
en matière de d'enregistrement des
données de garanties et cetera donc
progrès horizon mais on pourra aller
plus loin c'est une des proposition que
nous ferons c'est de d'ouvrir un horizon
pour la prochaine mandature européenne
qui explore ce sujet hein c'est au-delà
de sûr qui explore C sujet d'un
harmonisation pourra dire totale à
l'échelle européenne vous n'y êtes pas
hostile et vous pourriez contribuer je
vais vous poser mais vraiment 10
secondes monde il nous semble que la
phytopharmacovigilance est une véritable
innovation c'est ça fa le constat humble
que on ne peut pas tout prévoir avant la
mise sur le marché et que in vivo in
situe on peut constater des phénomènes
qu'ons pas prévu et qu'il faut ça permet
a 12 molécules qui sont réexamen
aujourd'hui certaines ont été retirées
enfin c'est donc ça produit ses effets
c'est financé par une taxe sur la sur
sur sur la phytopharmacie ça n'existe
pas à l'échelle européenne est-ce que le
gouvernement dans le cadre des
négociations autour du règlement
actuellement porte cette proposition je
sais que sur sur les innovations
françaises comme la reconnaissance du
biocontrôle S fait enfin c'est ça va
être ça va être fait et cetera sur son
son
côté circuit court pour son autorisation
tout tout ça est plutôt bien engagé il y
a rien sur on a pu le vérifier avec
l'fsa on a pu le vérifier avec les
députés européens ce sujet n'est pas
porté on n' pas senti une grande
inculturation de nos collègues européens
sur ce sujet alors il nous semble avec
le président et je pense l'ensemble des
commissaires que cette innovation
mériterait d'être poussée à l'échelle
européenne est-ce que vous pourriez
est-ce que vous l'avez envisagé est-ce
que vous pourriez l'envisager euh
envisager non parce qu'on a pour être
franc et transparent avec vous mais je
trouve que c'est une piste qui est assez
juste j'ajoute que quand même dans le
règlement sûr on touche pas une partie
du règlement au Règlement sur les
phytosanitaires euh et ça c'est qui qui
est le la façon dont on traite la
question des usages et je pense que
c'est un peu moi quand je suis arrivé
sur surû qui était déjà en partie engagé
c'est peut-être une partie un P manquant
de la réglementation de la
réglementation qui est portée donc un
j'entends votre vous avez raison sur la
Pharm phytopharmacovigilance qu'on a
besoin en continu de pouvoir suivre et
que ce que nous faisons au niveau
français est assez exemplaire et de
c'est un sujet qui pourrait être pter
plus ardemment si je peux dire au niveau
européen mais c'est vrai que il y a un
processus d'acculturation
euh qui n'est pas encore à l'œuvre avec
un certain nombre d'étatmembbres je me
permets sur sur l'orite parce qu'il me
reste un nombre de sujets à explorer
plus Prati pratique qui relève
directement de votre de votre direction
du ministère on é un peu sur des grands
concepts autorisation Europe onemble
c'est avoir entendu votre votre position
euh mais moi il me reste un quart
d'heure si on veut laisser 40 minutes à
l'ensemble des questions donc je vais
aller un petit peu sous forme
question-réponse un peu plus plus plus
rapide si si vous le voulez bien euh
vous avez été en charge du PSN nous
avons demandé à Julian Normandie
pourquoi son PSN avait été recalé par la
Commission européenne vous avez dû le
corriger hein c'est néanmoins
aujourd'hui et sans qu'on y passe trop
de temps parce que les débats ont lieu
dans l'hémicyclle il ont eu lieu dans
plein d'utres endroit vous avez pu vous
exprimer le PSN au vu de de très
nombreuxes Act acteur scientifique ONG
et d'une partie du monde syndical et du
monde du développement considère que ce
PSN s'il est populaire il marche c'est
que s'il vient consolider le revenu des
agriculteurs il il il n'a pas été pensé
notamment autour des écorégimes mais pas
seulement de façon à
enclencher vraiment la transition
agroécologique qu est la condition
syinequanon pour obtenir d'aller au-delà
de 25 30 % de résultats par des logiques
d'optimisation et de technosolution
voilà donc est-ce que on n pas à travers
cet instrument quand même du PSN rater
quelque chose de majeur et et si vous
l'avez raté alors que vous avez tout
tout tout tout toutes les convictions
pour vous avez eu toutes les convictions
pour le faire c'est sous quelle pression
avez-vous dû renoncer à faire un PSN
plus ambitieux pour la transition
sociale et écologique B j'ai pas
d'habitude d'être sous la pression y
compris la pression qui pouvait être la
la celle sur lequelle on a été au moment
de vous savez de faire un décalage entre
le buo et et les autres régimes dans les
corégimes donc les 30 € à l'hectare de
différentiel c'est un élément qui était
posé deuxième élément moi je pour le
coup c'est un des acccords sur le
contenu du PSN ENF au passage tous les
PSN d'Europe ont été recalés parce que
c'est le process enfin le PSN français
n'a pas été recalé plus que les autres
non les 27 ont été recalé ce que je
constate par ailleurs c'est que le PSN
français a été un des premiers à approué
donc on devait pas être si loin que ça
de la balle puisqueil a été approuvé en
août 2000
22 et que les derniers ont été approuvés
en mars ou avril
2023 donc c'est
bon pas dire qu'on est parfait hein mais
enfin constatons quand même qu'on a un
PSN qui a été oui comme tous les 27
jamais un PSN n'est approuvé au niveau
de la commission directement en disant
c'est parfait votre truc heureusement
d'ailleurs qu'il y ait du contradictoire
est une bonne nouvelle me semble-t-il
deuxième élément je considère que y
compris dans lescorégime ce qu'on fait
autour de la rotation des cultures des
des différentes BCAE notamment la BCA 8
les infrastructures écologiques qui sont
déjà cher enfin et cetera et cetera
c'est un élément qui permet d'engager
une trajectoire parce qu'on sait en quoi
et vous vous en êtes un déconvaincu
d'ailleurs en quoi ça modifier un
certain nombre de pratiques agricoles et
plutôt des changements de pratique
structurels qui permettent de contribuer
aussi à l'objectif de réduction des
produits phytosanitaires est-ce qu'il
fallait faire différemment plus on on
aura toujours des gens qui nous et puis
après tout ça fait partie du débat
contradictoire mais je ne considère pas
que le le PSN tel qu'il est posé ne soit
pas un PSN qui contribue lui aussi ça
doit pas servir cassal PSN mais qui
contribue lui aussi aux objectifs de
réduction des produits
phyos je notre interrogation c'est que
si on prend allez à 2 millions près hein
c'est on est 40 millions sur ecofito 30
millions sur les agences on a on a une
enveloppe de 70 millions mais il faut
l'intégrer pour nous en terme
d'efficacité dans les 600 millions c'est
ça à peu près du du PSN hein comme
leevier l'ordre d'idée c'est ça c'est
bon 600 millions et puis on pourrait
même les les concevoir dans l'ensemble
des des 9 10 milliards de la PAC et on
pourrait même les concevoir dans les
près de 20 milliards qui sont déployés
sous forme fiscale accompagnement et
cetera bon en tout cas la part de ce qui
est directement ciblé sur la transition
agroécologique nous paraît trop faible
pour être un levier puisque tout le
monde fait comme d'habitude et quand
tout le monde fait comme d'habitude ça
fait pas un changement systémique à la
hauteur de notre ambition donc il nous
semble monsieur le ministre et je je
relance pas le débat hein nous pointons
un décalage entre l'ambition affichée de
- 50 % de phito en 2027 et d'enclencher
un PSN sur 4 ans euh c'est on est sur va
trvisé mais voilà c'est bon donc voilà
il y a un décalage entre les deux la
question c'est il faut pas dire des
objectifs dont on se donne pas les
moyens pour les atteindre quoi donc il
nous semble que là il y a un décalage
sur l'utilisation des fonds publics mais
je vrais vous interroger maintenant sur
le continuum recherche développement
dans le plan ecofito 2 il y a deux
propositions majeures enfin il y a plein
de propositions il il y en a une qui
touche autour de défi et développement
et c'est un peu le Triangle des Bermudes
pardon il y a une proposition tout le
monde monde dit qu'il ne sait pas alors
les chambres les instituts les ministres
qu'on a vu personne ne sait ce que c'est
devenu il y avait une proposition qui
disait on passe de 2 à 3000 fermes votre
prédécesseur n'a pas su nous expliquer
pourquoi on est passé de 3000 à 2000 je
pense que vous avez rétabli le 2 à 3000
donc on a eu 1000 fermes je pas ce
qu'elles sont devenu mais à un moment
donné il y a eu des injonctions
contradictoires entre deux ministres en
peu de temps on réduisait la voilure sur
ecofito alors que quelques années avant
on avait dit qu'il fallait monter enfin
sur défi alors qu'il fallait monter donc
le laboratoire on l' grandrissait il a
été rétréci par Normandie vous l'avez
certainement ragrandi euh il y a une
sorte de discontinuité là vous pouvez
nous expliquer pourquoi de l'autre idée
était de dire il faut au moins 30000
fermes et je peux vous dire pourquoi je
j'étais à l'origine de cette proposition
avec avec les ingénieurs du cgaer c'est
que le développement dans les années 50
60 s'est fait sur l'idée que dès qu'un
agriculteur sur 7 était engagé un
agriculteur engagé on entraîit 7 voilà
bon c'était j'ai repris ce chiffre en
gros on a 160000 pullv en France 200000
agriculteurs qui utilise plus ou moins
des phyos donc on disait il faut 30000
agriculteurs engagés des grappes de 10
10 exploitants autour des fermes défi ce
processus là il a été si peu mis en
œuvre euh un petit peu comme les j'ai de
UF quoi ça il y a pas de massification
mais personne ne sait en répondre on
sait pas ce que c'est devenu donc c'est
quoi un plan écopyo qu'on pilote qui
affirme quelque chose qui n'est pas mis
en œuvre il y a un problème de
redevabilité il y a un problème de
pilotage il y a un problème de est-ce
que vous pouvez nous écl sur ce couple
3000 30000 dont on narrive pas à avoir
la moindre évaluation aujourd'hui c'est
quand même un mystère absolu il y a pas
d'argent qui a été perdu he il a pas été
mobilisé il a pas été quelque chose qui
s'est pas passé quoi
euh je réponds tout de suite à la
question juste pour dire vous avez dit
600 millions qui sont consacrés à la
réduction de
phyo oui dans dans le PSN oui j'ai bien
entendu mais je sais pas je sais pas
l'évaluer enfin franchement je sais pas
quand vous quand vous faites des aides
au maintien de
l'élevage donc au maintien des prairies
quand vous faites les infrastructures
agroécologiques quand vous faites vous
développez un plan protéin ou le
développement des légumineuses vous
contribuez quand vous faites
l'obligation de rotation des cultures
vous je
je ça ça pour le coup ça votre ce que le
chiffre que vous évoquez mériterait
qu'on le documente ensemble
collectivement parce que je pense que
c'est beaucoup plus que ça qui dans la
pâack
contribue y compris à une trajectoire
phyo au travers d'autres objectifs donc
après les fermes défill bon d' ils ont
quand même prouvé vous avez raison leur
efficacité et là vous me trouverez
évidemment sur le chemin y compris dans
les moyens supplémentaires qu'on a de de
renouveler à la fois la confiance et
sans doute de massifier un peu plus ce
réseau parce que c'est un réseau qui a
alors c'est pardon le dire c'est aussi
les mêmes critères mais c'est - 26 % de
réduction d'utilisation mais c'est avec
les mêmes bases de critères nu alors
peut-être que ça ça se rechallenge aussi
mais en tout cas c'est sur cette base là
qu'on
le il y a pas que les if qui sont
contrôlés enfin
mais
euh c'est vrai alors c'est valable on en
pararlera peut-être sur la question du
financement aussi c'est je trouve qu'on
a mis de l'argent et je pense que ça a
été bien utilisé mais on a du mal à
capitaliser et à
massifier c'estàdire l'élément
transformant et pour le coup là il me
semble que les instituts techniques mais
les Chambres d'agriculture parce que le
1 pour 7 ME vous êtes vous êtes plus
praticien que moi du du monde agricole
si je peux dire mais il me semble que le
1 pour 7 c'est un réseau de bouche à or
qui fonctionne assez bien dès lors qu'il
a une densité agricole euh
donc ça je suis assez d'accord avec
cette capacité de massification je pense
que le pan noir aujourd'hui sur lequel
il faut qu'on travaille c'est de passer
comment on est dans entre les les les
réseaux de ferme 2000
3000 j'ai pas d'avis sur le passage de
3000 à 2000 sans doute qu'il a eu un
élément de de dire on ressente sur un
certain nombre de priorité ENF je crois
pas qu'il y a d'ailleurs de de grief à
faire y compris à Julien deormandi sur
le sujet mais reconnaissons que ce
réseau fonctionnant on a plutôt intérêt
y compris dans la stratégie cofyo 2030
de le densifier mais après on on sa que
ça marche les fermes défi donc il faut
il en faut peut-être plus pour avoir
plus de réseaux de référence après le
sujet c'est l'étape plus loin oui alors
je pense que moi ça passe alors j'ai pas
de réponse si c'était facile parce que
j'ai pas la prétention de penser que que
c'est facile et que ce qu'on fait les
autres était était était inopérant je
pense que c'est le la question de la
massification est une question qui passe
pour moi par le réseau des des chambres
d'ailleurs elles sont très actives dans
le réseau des filles comme vous le savez
je ne vois que ça qu' permett de faire
deuxième élément je pense que c'est un
accompagnement à la fois individuel et
collectif parce que vous dites un pour 7
il y a besoin de se réassurer
personnellement parfois dans le
collectif mais parfois et encore plus
quand vous êtes sur une reconception de
système je pense que le le sujet alors
je pour être très honnête avec vous faut
voir comment on pourra le faire c'est
quand vous basculez le système et vous
n'êtes plus simplement je change mes bus
je change mon matériel qui vous permet
de réduire mais je reconçois mon système
d'exploitation vous avez deux TR années
d'incertitude dans vos pratiques y
compris de de d'incertitude de
production c'est ça qui est le moment le
plus complexe pour les agriculteurs
est-ce que c'est des est-ce qu'il faut
faire des dispositif d'accompagnement
spécifique on l'a fait au travers de
certains dispositifs fiscaux d'ailleurs
mais est-ce que je je je pense que ça ça
méritera dans le travail compris dans le
travail que vous allez produire vous de
regarder ce qu'on peut faire
oui on on peut dire que cette
défaillance de de de la recherche qui
qui a des qui apporent des solutions on
a reçu les institut hier arfalis ter ter
Innovia c'est ça Innovia je veux dire
univia c'estovia
Innovia on a aujourd'hui un paquet de
solutions d'innovation livre c'est la
question de la massification est
fondamentale alors il y a le levier des
chambres du développement qui doit être
financé on a chiffré un peu ce que
pourrait donner non pas un conseil
stratégique tel qu'il est banalisé
aujourd'hui c'est médiocre dansê on voit
les produits qui tous les 2 ans et demi
une demi-journée fait par à peu près
n'importe quel organisme et tout enfin
franchement ça me paraît pas sérieux
donc croit profondément à une mission
des chambres pour refaire de l'agronomie
et de l'accompagnement on l'a même
chiffré ça ne paraît pas insupportable
c'est une question de courage politique
d'orientation des financements mais il y
a une autre voie et là monsieur le
ministre il nous reste 5 minutes et je
vrais vraiment pour respecter les
collègues et la règle du moî Mo entre
les moitié- moitié entre le rapporteur
et les autres commissaires mais mais
franchement sur sur la séparation du
conseil de la vendre s'il y a une
responsabilité politique majeure me
semble-t-il tout le reste ça continue
comme avant et ça marche pas plus
qu'avant en gros voilà mais il y a un
truc qui qui qui qui était tenté en 2000
en
20004 2015 dans les propositions de
ecopyto 2 c'était les certificats
d'économie phytosanitaire or la mission
flash que nous avons conduit avec
Stéphane traver révèle sans aucune
ambigué a une quasi unanimité que ce fut
un échec or la DGL qu'on a auditionné
dès le début de cette commission et tout
nous dit c'est une question de temps
mais enfin on est on n'est pas à 10 % du
conseil stratégique on est sur une
impasse va falloir changer le règlement
pour que tous ceux qui n' pas ils l'ont
pas fait puissent le faire et cetera
mais non seulement il y a pas eu de
conseil stratégique enfin voilà mais il
semble de médiocre qualité banalisé et
et de le Conseil commercial a continué
comme avant nous osons dire avec
Stéphane traver en pire c'est en plus
une insécurité juridique avant il y
avait un engagement encore du du vendeur
de phito qui faisait une prescription
aujourd'hui on a quelque chose qui se
fait en off et qui est qui peut mettre
en danger d'ailleurs il y a les
premières premières insécurités jdiques
qui apparissent donc que vous êtes
ministre euh après Stéphane traver après
Didier Guillaume on peut dire que pour
Stéphane traver il faut que il faut
donner du temps au temps lui-même n'est
pas très convaincu par cette mesure
c'est une promesse présidentielle il la
met en œuvre dans des conditions qui
respectent pas le Parlement puisque le
décret trahit l'intention du Parlement
les assurances que le ministre bon tout
tout ça n'est pas très très bien Stéphan
traver n'a pas le temps DJ Guillaume et
peut-être ailleurs mais vous franchement
Julien Normandie et vous à un moment
donné je Normandie dit on a vu que ça
marchait pas mais pourquoi est-ce que
vous faites rien c'estd que c'est à un
moment donné on peut pas continuer c'est
c'est c'est un des leviers absolument
majeurs les certificats d'économie
phytosanitaire c'était une intuition
portée par des missions interministériel
porté par votre serviteur porté par par
qui avait connu des résistances he il y
a eu des des bon machin mais mais
c'était un levier vous l'avez alors
qu'on essae autre chose d'accord mais
mais quand c autre chose ne marche pas
combien de temps il faut à la puissance
publique pour revenir pour faire une
évaluation et revenir sur sa décision je
suis désolé de vous le dire mais dans
les auditions qu'on a eu avec la DJL on
a eu l'impression d'une forme de de de
de de de qu'on allait qu'il fallait
donner du temps au temps qu'on allait
aménager et cetera non il y a une
mission parlementaire et toute la
société civile vous le dira ça ne marche
pas donc est-ce que combien de temps il
faudra-t-il pour que vous en ayez
conscience qu'entendez-vous faire en la
matière je vais être rapide pour laisser
la place aux
question d'abord le conseil stratégique
vous dites il est banal je suis pas
complètement d'accord avec vous
simplement d'abord faut qu'on se défie
je le dis souvent au au représentants
des chambres
d'agriculture il faut qu'on se il faut
pas qu'on le banalise et en même temps
on va avoir un besoin de différents
conseils je je mets en garde quand même
alors je sais pas comment on le fait on
est en train d'y travailler au ministère
sur la multiplication des conseils
stratégiques qui sur les phyos qui sur
le carbone qui sur le bien-être qui sur
la qui enfin vous allez avoir des gens
dans les exploitations tous les matins
pour faire un conseil stratégique mais
je sais qu'on partagera mais il faut une
fois qu'on partage qui est parfois un
constat d'échec et qui fait que les
agriculteurs disent ah non votre conseil
de plus j'en veux pas et il rentrent
vous rentrer avec le Conseil conseill
chambres sont plutôt bien vu hein
normalement dans les exploitations enfin
il vont arriver le conseill chambre en
disant ça y est je suis reparti pour une
journée qu'on va me facturer oui mais on
vous en prend 80 % enfin c'est du temps
enfin bref donc faut sur la notion de
conseil il faut quand même qu'on essaie
de penser un truc qui soit un peu plus
global parce que la question du phito
n'est pas délié de la question du
carbone de la question de voyez donc il
faut qu'on essaie de penser un truc un
peu plus global c'est juste pour dire ça
deuxème élément vous dites combien de
temps d'abord l'intention des
législateurs et j'en étais en
2018 et donc j'ai j'ai vootter ce texte
en pensant que c'était une bonne idée
bon c'est pas mal en France qu'on se
dise on a essayé quelque chose je dis ça
sous l'œil de Frédéric descroosille sur
les question des Galim de se dire on a
fait un premier texte on fait un 2uxè on
refait des ajustements on fait un 3è
c'est la loi qui qui a été produite l'an
dernier bon je trouve pas ça idiot que
le législateur sans dire ça marche ça
marche pas enfin de dire voyez c'est un
échec de dire bah comment réajuste que
les acteurs économiques réagissent ou
les acteurs tout court ils réagissent
aux injonctions qu'on leur donne au
travers de la loi c'est c'estes loi voté
séparation V conseil et tout le monde a
pensé de bonne fois que ça allait
fonctionner bon vous
dites ça mériterait qu'on revisionne la
vidéo savoir commment on l'avait dit à
l'époque non
maisunème non mais il y a pas de GRF
entre nous mais il me semble qu'on était
plutôt à se dire que ça allait dans le
bon dans le bon sens euh donc oui vous
avez un rapport que vous avez produit
avec avec Stéphane travers sur le quel
on travaille pour s'en inspirer lui
aussi parce que je pense que le travail
parlementaire ça sert à ça he c'est pas
pour mettre dans des placards ou sous
une pile et pour regarder ce qu' on doit
en tirer comme conséquence à court terme
pour pas mettre les les les agriculteurs
en situation d'impasse donc c'est une
question de décret pour faire en sorte
que on les mette pas en situation
d'impasse du conseil et donc de ces
certificats deuxième élément de regarder
ce que ça peut produire en terme
d'évolution il y aura peut-être des
initiatives législatives à prendre et
puis trème élément pour le pour le le
CPP enfin les certificats de phyo on est
on a un décret en d'État qui est en
cours de de d'examen au Conseil d'État
et qui vise à retravailler sur la
question de la sanction financière parce
que c'était un élément moteur me
semble-t-il sous forme
contraventionnelle mais sur lequel on
est en train de travailler après c'est
ça reconnaissons quand vous regardez les
chiffres que vous dites c'était un
formidable levier alors on me dir on l'a
peut-être pas il a peut-être pas vécu
assez longtemps enfin quand vous
regardez la
trajectoire il a été tué dans l'œuf
ouais je je me permets parce que
vraiment il faut respectueux des 40
minutes qui vont au collègues de de vous
dire juste deux derniers mots si on
j'aurais des des scrupules il y a deux
rapports que cette commission d'enquête
alors il n'était pas je fais pas de
mauvais procès il n'était pas camouflé
secret et j'ai l'ambiguité sur le fait
que soyez été obligé de les publier mais
tout de même moi je suis assez fier je
dis devant les commissaires que cette
commission d'enquête est peut-être
suscité réactié la publication d'une
part d'un rapport des inspections sur le
financement et le pilotage des cofitau
on n' pas un mot à rajouter tellement le
la sanction est terrible sur pas votre
période mais sur l'ensemble de la
période concernée il était un petit peu
il était publié de façon trop discrète
donc on a permis de le remettre à jour
on a pu auditionner les les auteurs de
cette mission on a rien à rajouter al je
peux vous dire on ne s'appuiera dans
cette mission que sur la science et sur
les rapports d'État hein fait par l'État
ça suffit largement à porter le le
pldoyer il a pas besoin d'en rajouter
par contre on avait pas goûté que lors
des auditions qu'on avait réalisé alors
qu'on vous avez interrogé vous n aez pas
communiqué spontanément il a fallu faire
une saisie sur sur pièce et sur place
pour obtenir le les documents enfinon
vous demande ces documents
officiellement pour qu'on ait le rapport
sur les sur sur la séparation du conseil
et de la vente parce que c'était un
élément important sur par les chiffres
qui donnent la critique du système qu'il
comportait alors je sais que votre
argument sera de dire c'est un document
technique interne au gouvernement le
Parlement notamment lorsqu'il fait une
mission parlementaire monsieur le
ministre lorsqu'il fait une mission
parlementaire avec un ancien ministre et
un député qui a porté ses questions dans
l'hémicycle pour pour le respect du
Parlement il est quand même bon qu'on
lui communique toutes les pièces qui
sont à notre disposition pour alimenter
son débat on a au mois au printemps
dernier l'été dernier avec Stéphane
Travert fait des auditions sans qu'on
ait communication en l'absence de cette
commission d'quête on a pas eu
communication d'un rapport qui était
très précieux pour pour évaluer le
conseil et la vente c'est le seul
reproche dans le dialogue que nous avons
avec vous que je voulais vous faire mais
je je mentirai si je ne le faisait pas
voilà c'est bien d' un c'est bien noté
de euh moi je considère qu'il y a des
pièces alors après il y a parfois des
rapports qui sont et ou techniqu ou
strictement internes pas idot que on
puisse aussi que ceux qui veulent
s'exprimer puisse le faire de
façon directe avec le ministère mais moi
comme vous le savez quand on a eu un
autre débat l'autre jour je met rien
sous le tapis et donc j'essaie de faire
les choses en transparence donc on a pas
de difficulté je crois qu'en plus ce
rapport était en cours de finalisation à
l'époque où vous l'aviez je je crois 2
mars on
aqu ouais oui non mais le travail était
en cours je crois que le travail enc
était en cours enfin
bon euh monsieur le ministre je vais
passer la parole à nos collègues vous
êtes nombreux à poser des questions je
vais les prendre deux par deux je vous
demande d'être le plus concis possible
dans les questions que vous posez
monsieur minist je vous demande
également d'être concis dans vos
réponses par respect pour les mes de la
Commission on pourit prendre une heure
de plus on ne l'a pas on va faire avec
au passage je vous pose moi-même de
questions mais les réponses c'est
pratiquement oui ou non je rebondis sur
ce que vous avez dit sur l'horizon zéro
en fait en disant pourquoi est-ce que ce
secteur a ne pas utiliser de chimi deux
questions très rapidement le modèle
français 2014 c'est-à-dire on fusionne
au sein d'une agence indépendante
analyse et gestion du risque donc ce
n'est plus le ministre qui prend la
décision d'autorisation de mise en
marché ce modèle- làà vous semble-t-il
exportable au niveau européen peut-on
est-ce qu'à votre avis euh dans les
contacts que vous avez on pourrait la
France pourrait convaincre peut-être pas
au niveau de l'fsa est-ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer que je sais pas horizon de 5 ou
10 ans il y ait une agence commune un
certain nombre de pays par exemple avant
que ça passe directement à l'fsa sur ce
modèle- làà je précise au passage que il
y a a une nuance de sensibilité entre le
rapporteur et moi sur cette question
parce que plus d'indépendance dans la
décision garantit la confiance mais
moins de responsabilité du politique
ajoute à son discrédit et là on est
quand même sur la définition du risque
acceptable donc pour moi la question
elle est quand même politiquement posé
mais est-ce que ce modèle français est
exportable
de puisque vous avez l'air de dire c'est
ma sensibilité également se passera
jamais complètement chimie et ça est
même au fond même pas forcément
souhaitable est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à un durcissement de la
phytopharmaco la phytopharmacie
durcissement dans les sanctions des
mises en marché de produits non
conformes durcissement si on prend le
modèle de la santé de la pharmacie les
répartiteurs les grossiste pharmacien
leur marge est plafonné par la loi
est-ce que on est-ce que vous seriez
favorable à
un quelque chose d'inminist ministère de
la Santé qui durcisse considérablement
la mise en marché l'utilisation des
produits pharmaceutique sur le modèle de
ce qu'est euh la politique publique de
la
santé euh premier sujet alors pour le
coup le premier sujet le modèle français
est un modèle unique hein ce modèle
anè moi j'ai tendance à penser que nous
sommes par nature les meilleurs en
Europe mais il faut se demander pourquoi
les autres ont fait différemment et ça
ne remet pas en cause que j'ai dit au
début de la réunion mais il faut qu'on
puisse se poser la question parce que un
contre 26 faut quand même parfois
s'interroger
ça serait mieux en tout cas que nous
ayons au niveau européen un modèle qui
soit un
peu fonctionnement identique parce que
nous avons un modèle très atypique on a
construit un modèle très atypique à la
fois d'indépendance je je c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit ce que j'ai dit à l'époque
et ce qui a motivé monsieur Poti à me
poser une question et après que l'idée
émerge avec vous de créer une commission
d'enquête mais ça peut pas être délié
d'une décision politique à un moment
d'Ille la dérogation à 120 jours c'est
une décision
politique posé dans des termes
scientifiques et techniques mais c'est
quand même une décision politique parce
qu'à un moment forcément vous prenez une
pume sur ces sujets là parce que ça
déplaî aux uns ou aux autres donc j'ai
donc donc oui je suis je je sais pas si
c'est possible mais ça serait bien qu'on
pose la question au niveau européen mais
sans arrogance qu'on a parfois nous
Français de dire pourquoi ça marche
comme ça chez vous comment ça marche
chez nous et qu'est-ce qu'il aurait
quelque chose de de conjoint parce que
c'est un modèle assez atypique et c'est
parfois interrogé compris au niveau
européen mais ça serait mieux parce
qu'on PE on parle pas des mêmes façons
de fonctionner et tout le monde
reconnaît par ailleurs le travail de
qualité de l'an donc c'est pas ça le
sujet c'est le fait qu'on est les deux
dans la même instance donc ça c'est une
question deuxième question alors je là
vous me posez un peu une colle je vois
pas l'intérêt que ça aurait
de ENF il me semble que ce que le modèle
qu'on a autorisation de mise sur le
marché avec une double au fond un double
regard européen sur les substances et
nationales sur les autorisations de sur
le marché j'ai du voir ce que ça
apporterait de plus en terme de régime
de sanction
sur peut-être de la responsabilité de
ceux qui mettent sur le marché c'est ça
que vous avez en tête je pense
simplement à ce que dans tous les
esprits des opérateurs et du public de
la société civile il soit il rentre dans
une sorte de culture l'idée que le
recours au produits phytopharmaceutiqu
fait l'objet d'une vigilance d'une
rigueur et d'une exigence comparable à
celle qui vaut pour les produits de
santé difficile d'avoir une opinion
définitive ce que je constate ceci étant
sans qu'on ait déjà cette disposition ce
que je constate c'est que les metteurs
en marché on va les appeler comme ça
enfin ceux qui qui produisent sont très
vigilants désormais he sur ces sujetsl
parce qu'ils savent ce que ça peut
entraîner et et ce qui fait d'ailleurs
que souvent on dit on dit vous aveit
interdit des molécules souvent c'est
parce qu' il y a pas d'interdiction
c'est simplement que il y a pas de
demande de
réhomologation et c'est sans doute pour
le motif que vous évoqué donc il y a une
forme de régulation qui s'est déjà faite
cont tenu de ce qu'on peut être des
contentieux de nature divers donc
l'essentiel des molécules qui sont
interdites y compris en France c'est des
molécules sur lesquelles en fait il n'y
a pas eu de redemande de mise en marché
est-ce que si on avait un CG plus cadré
ça serait peut-être plus ça éviterait
que dans uncertitude juridique dans
laquelle il soit ils disent bah non je
fais pas ma demande de réautorisation
peut-être en tout cas c'est une piste je
veux pas vous donner une réponse
définitive que je ça mériterait d'être
creusé en tout cas je remercie pour vos
réponses euh je vais prendre donc madame
Thomas monsieur de fournass l'un après
l'autre je poser vos questions encore
une fois euh et essayer de condenser euh
l'objet de vre question et Monsieur le
Ministre essayer d'être cons aussi dans
votre dans vos réponses parce que il y a
six membres de commission qui souhaitent
vous poser des questions madame
Thomas merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous savez je vous
ai écouté hier matin avec beaucoup
d'attention lorsque vous êtes intervenu
sur France Info et je voulais vous poser
une première question euh qui est en
lien avec un sujet qui nous est cher
dans cette commission d'enquête c'est le
sujet de l'eau et vous avez déclaré hier
matin que dans notre pays plutôt à
climat
tempéré nous découvrons que nous avons
depuis une quinzaine d'années maintenant
une arythmie climatique exacerbée par
des phénomènes exceptionnels l'eau va
être trop rare ou trop abondante je
voulais vous interroger sur ces
phénomènes d'eau trop abondantes comme
récemment en Bretagne et surtout dans le
pas decaléis qui rendent beaucoup plus
vulnérables les points de captage d'eau
et nos réseaux d'eau plus globalement
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête nous les savons sens et
stratégique pour la préservation de
notre santé environnementale mais aussi
pour la santé humaine dans ce contexte
comment assurer leur nécessaire
protection notamment à l'égard des
produits phytosanitaires et leurs
conséquences et la conséquence de leur
dilution dans la
nature deuxè question que je souhaitais
vous poser c'est au sujet des MAEC de
2015 à 2022 les premières mesures
agro-environnementales ont connu un
grand succès et une dynamique plutôt
enthousiasmante pour promouvoir les
transitions mais dans la deuxème
génération programmée dans le cadre de
la PAC
202327 le compte n'y est pas et les
aides ne sont plus les mêmes sans doute
la recentralisation de ce dispositif
a une part de responsabilité là-dedans
la France serait même l'État de l'Union
européenne allouant la plus faible part
du second pilier au MAEC vous le savez
monsieur le ministre les attentes sont
très importante pour l'obtention d'une
enveloppe budgétaire supplémentaire en
atteste le courrier signé par 35
parlementaires bretons ma question est
la suivante comment à la fois prenez la
réduction de l'usage des produits
phytosanitaires dans notre pays et
laisser le sentiment de ne pas
accompagner suffisamment un outil majeur
dans le cadre de nos transitions je
crois que la responsabilité de la
puissance publque en la matière elle est
elle est forte et dernière question
j'essaierai de la poser rapidement
je voudrais revenir sur la définition du
risque acceptable qui a été esquissé par
Monsieur le Président à propos du
glyphosate nous le savons tous entre
2018 et 2023 la France est passée de
l'opposition à l'abstention sur le
renouvellement du du
glyphosat alors je ne vous demande pas
de de motiver aujourd'hui cette
abstention parce que vous avez sans
doute de bonnes raison à nous donner
mais je voudrais savoir pourquoi nous
avons basculé de l'opposition à
l'abstention et qu'est-ce qui a changé
dans l'impact et les usages de ce
produit pour modifier et pour motiver
pardon une telle variation de point de
vue est-ce la science certains
impératifs économiques et je rajouterai
aussi peut-être une autre réflexion sur
des impératifs géopolitiques je vous
remercie merci chers collègue monsieur
de
fournasse merci Monsieur le le Président
j'ai j'ai trois questions à vous poser
monsieur le ministre la première son si
je je fais partie de de ceux qui
regrettent la réponse que vous avez
donné monsieur le rapporteur sur le sur
le le statut de de l'anè le le le
ministre Jan De Normandie a très bien
expliqué hier le fait que personne ne
contestait l'AVE scientifique qui
pouvait être rendu par l'ances mais que
derrière il y avait aussi des
responsabilités politique à prendre sur
le maintien d'unee production d'une
filière et que le directeur de nous a
très bien expliqué lors des auditions
lors de l'audition qu'il a pu faire ici
que il n'avait pas cette faculté
d'adaptation d'adaptation à à cette à
cet avis scientifique voilà et ça ça
pose un énorme problème parce que on
sait bien
que la marge de manœuvre d'un ministre
de l'Agriculture il est déjà fortement
diminué par les les compétences
transféré à l'Union européenne c'est
quand même problématique que de l'autre
côté il soit aussi bloqué par une
administration sur laquelle il n'a pas
la main et c'est c'est une vraie
question qu'on se pose c'est aujourd'hui
quelle est la marge de manœuvre d'un
d'un ministre de
l'Agriculture le deuxème c'est sur le la
question des des critères de de
quantification alors je je sais que
Monsieur rapporteur n'aime pas qu'on en
parle parce que en réalité ça pose un
énorme problème et et je vois je vois
même dans la présentation que vous avez
faite au début de cette audition que que
vous ne semblez pas visiblement voir le
problème qu'il y a derrière le le nou et
à forceué sur le QSA je je prends un
exemple très patique moi je suis
viticulteur en sortant des produits CMR
j'ai dégradé mon
ifft et par nature le le NODU donc on
voit bien qu'il y a un problème dans la
quantification c'est que on est sur une
sur une une appréciation de la baisse
des Plô sur un un un point de vue
quantitatif alors qu'on est incapable de
voir l'aspect qualitatif et alors je
vous parle même pas du QSA parce que
quand on remplace un produit CMR pour
lutter contre mu à 200 g hectare par un
soufre à 6 ou voire 10 kg d'hectare
forcément on dégrade le le QSA mais on n
pas capable de voir dans cette
dégradation que finalement il y a une
amélioration qualitative et ça c'est un
c'est un énorme problème qu' va falloir
quand même régler parce que sinon on
continuera par votre voie aussi puisque
vous l'avez fait au début de cette
audition à à à à à dire qu'on a des
dégradations mais qui sont des des
dégradations du nu qui sont en fait des
dégradations vertueuses et moi je
voudrais rajouter aussi que je ne
voudrais pas si vous voulez quand je
vois dans ma circonscription des
viticulteurs qui font face à de graves
difficultés économique
euh et et et que se multiplie des vignes
qui ne sont plus entretenues et et donc
plus plus traité qu'on se réjouissent
d'une baisse d' l'utilisation des phyos
euh parce qu'en fait il y a plus de
traitement parce que parce que les les
ticulteurs ne sont plus en capacité de
d'entretenir leur leurs exploitations 3è
question
euh sur le la la la question de
l'interdiction sans solution on a bien
entendu votre discours jearais quand
même dire qu'il y a eu quand même des
interdictions sans solution avec des des
menaces sur sur certaines productions
mais il y a un autre aspect que vous ne
que vous n'abordez pas c'est celui de la
dégradation de la compétitivité j'ai je
vous ai aussi écouté sur sur France
Inter vous vous êtes réjouis du fait que
la France avait qu enfin avait été
beaucoup plus vertueuse que beaucoup
d'autres pays européens
et et mondiaux sur la la baisse du
glyphosate en argant d'une baisse de 30
% des usages cette baisse de 30 % des
usages elle s'est peut-être accompagnée
de solutions derrière mais qui ce sont
les solutions qui sont plus plus
coûteuses et donc il y a une dégradation
de la compétitivité
de de de l'agriculture alors vous
semblez dire que vous vous positionnez
sur ligne de crête en disant pas
d'interduction sur solution veut
préserver la production euh on oublie
quand même que la production agricole
elle s'effondre et qu'elle est du en en
très grande partie à une dégradation de
la compétitivité et donc je voudrais
savoir Monsieur le Ministre comment vous
abordez cette cette question au-delà de
la réponse sur les sur les clauses
miroir parce que les clauses murar on
sait que pour l'instant elle fonctionne
très peu et qu'en plus elle ne concerne
pas et ça vous l'avez rappelé la la
concurrence du marché commun qui qui est
la première concurrence de l'agriculture
française merci cher collègue monsieur
le ministre oui merci c'est madame la
députée d'abord sur la question de la
vulnérabilité alors c'est en général
c'est pas simplement au moment des
épisodes de trop d'eau j'imagine que
vous me posiez la question de la
vulnérabilité des des périmètres de
protection de captage ou décaptage
c'était hors hors une phénomène
d'inondation dans un phénomène
d'inondation cataclysmique si je peux
dire ça pour le coup on est face à des
éléments qui nous dépassent et on peut
pas garantir tout à tout le monde tout
le temps quand vous avez 200 mm en 5
jours ce qui est encore le cas du pas de
Calet je dis au passage que quand même
ça pose la question du cycle je je peux
pas me priver de dire quand même
que la question des retenus d'eau quand
il y en a trop est quand même une bonne
question on a passé l'été à nous
expliquer qu' en avait pas assez ce qui
était vrai et vous m'avez pas trouvé sur
le chemin de dire que il fallait pas
réguler enfin là on en a vraiment trop
hein et et sans doute on aurait alors je
dis pas que ça résoudrait les problèmes
d'inondation parce que les masses d'eau
sont tellement gigantesques que c'est
pas le sujet mais quand même de se dire
dans le bon sens parce qu'il est pas
impossible qu'en Juen prochain on se
disent on manque d'eau donc on va pas
alterner trop d'eau pas d'assz d'eau
trop d'eau pas assez d'eau sans dire
est-ce si j'en gardais un petit peu dans
un cycle qui ne vient pas
obérer la nature des NAP quand même
enfin j'étais malheureusement sûr parce
que c'est comme ça nous sommes face à
des faomèes et de la rythmie qui est
trop forte donc bref je le dis quand
même au passage sur la vulérabilité il y
a bien un axe qui est dédié
spécifiquement dans écophyo c'est l'axe
3 si j'ai bonne mémoire dans écophyo
2030 pour la question de la des
protections de captage ça fait partie
des éléments donc c'est changement de
pratique c'est la question des ha c'est
la question de réduction de phyo c'est
la question de la part qu'on peut donner
au bio donc il me semble que là-dessus
on a quelque chose avec à la fois une
une surveillance régulière et puis un
guide de
gestion les périmètres de protection de
capage en version en de captage pardon
en version élargie c'est des millions
d'hectares donc c'est pas une question
qui c'est pas juste autour du château
d'eau he c'est pas juste autour de
fourrage pour qu'on soit clair entre
nous donc c'est une question qui doit se
traiter à l'échelle territoriale plutôt
par une des mesures de réduction deuxème
élément sur les
ma alors d'abord je peux il y a deux
choses que lequel je suis en désaccord
c'est un c'est pas parce que c'est
l'état que c'est moins bien parfois
c'est mieux quand c'est les
collectivités parfois c'est mieux quand
c'est l'état je connais parfois des
politiques publiques je suis un élu
régional un élu municipal un élu
communautaire donc je suis très à l'aise
he dans mes baskets sur le sujet j'ai vu
des politiques publiques mal mis en
œuvre par des collectivités locales ça
personne n'est parfait ni au niveau
national ni au niveau déconcentré parce
que cette espèce de de ritournel ou de
fable sur le thème c'est tellement mieux
quand c'est des collectivités ça ça
mérite d'être challengé aussi parce
qu'il y aurit quelque chose d' un peu
aveugle en tout cas moi c'est pas ce que
j'ai vu dans mon territoire peut-être
que le Loir cher on est'est pas bon he
mais enfin quand même c'est pas toujours
ce que j'ai vu et que tous les autres
départements sont sont formidables mais
je je fais confiance aux collectivités y
compris sur les sujets qu'on évoque là
je pense que d'embarquer les
collectivités sur la question des
captages sur il y a des tas de sujets
sur lesquel on peut embarquer les
collectivités donc le sujet ma c'est pas
un sujet état à région même s'il y a eu
un débat sur les mesures dites surfaciqu
deuxième élément on met les mêmes moyen
que la période précédente trè élément
c'est pas complètement éconoclasse de
dire ce qu'on a toujours fait dans les
politiques agricoles on grade on monte
en gradation sur les exigences qui sont
demandées dans les m on reconduit pas
les mes moi j'ai j'ai connu quand
j'étais petit quand je dis souvent dans
d'autres endroits les premières ma et au
fur et à mesure dans la génération
suivante de programmation on remontait
un peu les exigences la Meque elle vient
compenser des pertes liées à des
changements de pratique qui sont
demandés une fois que le changement de
pratique est acté sur 5 ans ou sur 10
ans bah on monte un peu en sinon on
reste dans un statu qu qui n'est pas
souhaitable y compris pour la
trajectoire de réduction des phyos trè
TR élément pour ne pas vous laisser sans
réponse làessus on est en train de
travailler y compris sur la région qui
vous préoccupe le plus pour essayer de
combler alors on peut pas simplement me
dire il manque 500 millions où est
l'argent
oui il manque 5 milliards aussi hein
mais parfois mais je veux dire il faut
qu'on essaie de le faire en
responsabilité budgétaire ceci étant on
est en train d'expertiser notamment ce
que ce qui était les engagements qui
avaient été pris c'est pas un grief par
les agences de
l'eau 70 millions première intention
avec des crédits su par an je parle qui
permettrait de résoudre donc je une
partie voir une très grande partie de la
question il y a des régions qui n'ont
pas débordé d'enveloppe he pays Loire
région Centre enfin bon il y a des
régions qui débordent d'enveloppe je
fais pas de griief alors vraiment
croyez-moi au breton d'avoir une
enveloppe qui est le double quasiment ou
60 % de plus que ce qui était dans la
précédente programmation mais essayons
de travailler ensemble à trouver des
solutions financières sans se dire il y
a il y a qu'à faucon parce que c'est un
tout petit peu compliqué d'aller
chercher 350 millions sachant que j'ai
un budget en hausse d' 1,3 milliard sur
l'agriculture
quand même sur les sujets de
planification quasi exclusivement ça
m'était quasiment reproché l'autre jour
dans audition au Sénat donc il me semble
que c'est un élément sur lequel il faut
qu'on arrive à travailler
important j'ai oublié ce que vous voulez
me dire sur le risque acceptable j'ai
juste Notter définition du risque
acceptable excusez-moi
mais ah ou pardon ça y est je suis
rebranché merci monsieur le
Président bah on a fait vous dites
qu'est-ce qui a changé ce qui a changé
c'est qu'on a 30 % deème élément on a
regardé aussi ce que dit l'fsa et ce qui
produit d'ailleurs la proposition de la
Commission je rappelle que le rapport de
l'fsa il est aussi soumis à des travaux
qui ont été en partie rédigés par l'an
j'ai pas l'an s variable donc il y a
aussi ça de
nouveau c'est des éléments N et ça n'a
pas empêché quand bien même nous avions
ça de dire essayons de trouver une
trajectoire de réduction du glyphosate
ça fera le joint après avec ce que la
réponse à Monsieur de fournasse donc
c'est ça le et pourquoi la position
française celle-là c'est non on peut pas
interdire totalement parce qu'il y a des
impasses il y a vraiment des impasses
oui il y a des solutions qui permettent
sans réduire la en tout cas sur le
glyphosate c'est évident il y a des tas
de solutions de de réduction qui ne
passent pas par une baisse de la
compétitivité sur le glyphosate dans un
certain nombre alors ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas dans certains cas des
impasses je rappelle que d'ailleurs on a
en plus commencé nous il y a très
longtemps à réduire les usages l' fait
dans ma propre commune sur les espaces
communaux sur les espaces privés et
c'est là-dessus souvent qu'il y a des
risques parce que les usagers sont sont
un peu comment dirais-je mal renseignés
sur les sur la façon dont il faut
appliquer les produits on a vécu tous
les uns et les autres monsieur de
fourour je vois bien que vous regrettez
mon avis sur l'an mais moi je pense
qu'il faut mettre aussi l'an en
situation de responsabilité c'est le
travail qu'on a fait plutôt intelligent
attendez je je je c'est le travail qu'on
fait on a eu un épisode s sm au maccord
mais sur le prulfocar on a fait un
travail intelligent d'évolution des
pratiques de prescription en terme
d'usage qui permet de réduire sans
interdire dans une logique de
responsabilité la responsabilité de l
elle est et croyez-le quand il regardent
les molécules il regardent
globalement les
choses c'est ce qu'on a fait sur prul
faocarb et moi je trouve que réouvrir
cette boîte là sera une erreur au-delà
de ce que a été dit par le président des
CR c'estàd le modèle an qui est un peu
particulier il me semble qu' revenir
là-dessus à la fin les dérogations à 120
jours c'est une décision politique le
débat qu'on peut avoir avec LAN sur les
usages en disant bah qu'est-ce que vous
proposez comme usage différents qui
permettent de réduire prulfo c'est
plutôt une affaire de volatilité comme
vous le savez bon on travaille
techniquement avec les instituts
techniques et là je trouve qu'on a fait
un travail qui était plutôt à la fois
une trajectoire de
réduction de limitation d'un certain
nombre de de contraintes que ça faisait
poser pour les voisins en terme de
dérive mais je pense que c'est plutôt
une bonne méthode sur les critères de
quantification je je vous êtes plus
spécialiste que moi pour beaucoup
d'entre vous si on commence à toucher au
critères
oui je vois bien qu'il y a ces effets de
bord là enfin c'est les critères qu'on
s'est choisi il y a une quinzaine
d'années ou a une dizaine d'années je
retourne vers mes équipes les critères
nou les IFT et cetera donc on peut pas
faire évoluer les critères donc que vous
puissiez poser cette question mais je
vois pas quel est le modèle alternatif
qu'on propose au fond que le modèle
alternatif c'est un modèle qui pu nous
permettre de quantifier devant l'opinion
publique devant les agriculteurs devant
la puissance publique est-ce qu'on a
réduit ou
pas c'est pas la question de savoir si
ça ça marche ça marche pas enfin le
critère marche marche pas c'est juste
est-ce que on peut quantifier une
trajectoire si on commence à changer les
critères au milieu d'une trajectoire
qu'on essaie de trouver me semble-t-il
ça va être assez compliqué après vous
avez
évoqué les interdictions sans solution
euh oui ça ça dans certains cas ça
dégrade vous avez raison ça dégrade la
souveraineté mais c'est aussi parce
qu'on a essayé la réduction des phyos
c'est c'est on change complètement du
modèle dans lequel on a vécu et qui
était euh euh qui était un modèle qui
qui a montré ses performances de ce
point de vue-là de compétition c'était
on avait un une maladie un produit en
préventif ou en curatif on sait ce que
ça peut produire vous êtes élu dans un
territoire on sait ce que ça peut
produire sur les contraintes que ça met
sur les on vient d'en parler sur les
périmètres de protection de captage et
cetera et je crois que pour le coup
c'est pas une part de la société c'est
pas des injonctions seulement des ONG il
y a une demande des collectivités il y a
une demande des citoyens de se dire il
faut qu'on protège nos captages et donc
il y a des conséquences et c'est pas un
Grif qu'il faut faire aux agriculteurs
je pense que tout le monde devrait
regarder pourquoi on a fait ça à
l'époque mais la nécessité si vous
voulez pas que ça ça crée des impasses y
compris des impasses économique que je
suis très vigilant là-dessus et vous le
savez d'ailleurs c'est de faire en sorte
qu'on qu'on non pas seulement qu'on
accompagne les transitions qu'on
anticipe il y a rien de pire que ce
qu'on a fait sur la
cerise rien de pire c'est un truc qui
m'énerve tous les jours parce que je
continue à avoir des producteurs en face
de moi qui me disent pourquoi vous avez
interdit ce produit qui marchait mais
d'abord parce qu' mais parce que
simplement il y avait des problèmes de
de
cancéragité
le cancer
avéré sur ces produits là bon alors je
vais pas revenir sur ça au nom de la
souveraineté je reviendrai pas là-dessus
simplement on aurait anticipé il y a 10
ans des solutions
alternatives c'est je parle de
laadosophile Suzuki çaait été mieux donc
à chaque fois qu'on produit une
interdiction alors là pour le coup on
vient taper la souveraineté de même que
moi j'ai entendu des gens à longueur de
tribune il y a des alternatives sur les
néonique bah à la vérité ça rejoint un
truc quelque chose pard que disait le
rapporteur potier aujourd'hui on a pas
de solution totalement opérante sur la
sur la jaunice non pas total parce que
il y a peu de métiers je parlais sur les
phyos il y a peu de métiers on dit bon
c'est pas grave vous perdrez 30 % de
votre production cette année
le modèle il va tenir non il va pas
tenir le modèle il y a il y a pas une
entreprise en France qui puisse
supporter 30 % de baisse de production
de façon erratique voire 60 ce qui a été
le cas de la crise jaunis de 2020 sans
que ça fasse effondrer le système
économique donc c'est ça qu'il faut s
éviter ça je suis d'accord avec vous
c'està dire que et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut anticiper c'est pour ça que le pnri
on en a pas parlé mais le pnri bave est
assez exemplaire parce qu'on a mis tout
le monde autour de la table y compris
l'ensemble des acteurs de la chaîne pour
le faire et j'ajoute un dernier point
parfois ça peut produire un surcoup
parce qu'il y a des exigences
supplémentaires après il y a un débat
dans la chaîne de valeur parce que les
grands distributeurs ils ont leur
responsabilité
he les transformateurs aussi dans ce
dans les exigences qu'on montre ça peut
pas être à la charge de l'agriculture
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas les objectifs de
la loi égalime et donc il faut qument en
responsabilité on dise et qu'on ait un
débat dans l'opinion publique pour dire
la qualité ça a un coût et comme ça a un
coût ça a un prix alors je ne mésestime
pas les sujets de nos compatriotes sur
le pouvoir d'achat c'est pas le sujet
mais ça fait 15 ans qu'on parle de du
prix agricole ils ont été très bas alors
aujourd'hui on a un moment
inflationniste qui est douloureux pour
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes ça
c'est un autre c'est un sujet de nature
sociale qu'il faut traiter aussi mais la
grande distribution certains opérateurs
nous ont vendu tous les matins que le
bon prix c'était le prix le plus bas ça
vous faites pas la compétitivité oui on
fait de l'agriculture différente chez
nous que dans la plupart des pays du
monde c'est un prix parce que c'est un
coout donc c'est pas simplement moi mon
compétiteur c'est pas le Brésil no
compétiteurs c'est voisins européens et
donc la question de la rémunération doit
être posée à chaque fois dans ce genre
d'exerci chaque fois on m'a dit c'est
pas grave les consommateurs pr non au
milieu il y a la grande distrip qui fait
pas qui fait pas ce jeul pas se raconter
l'histoire
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame elle
et ensuite madame
pochon merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vais vous poser
à la fois des questions en mon nom mais
je vais également en poser une au nom de
Nicole LEP qui avait une question très
importante et d'ailleurs je vais en
profiter je vais commencer par la
question de Nicole LEP que je vais lire
pour ne pas écorcher ses propos donc
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs sont
conscients de la nécessaire réduction de
l'utilisation des produits phy et
notamment les les jeunes générations sur
un niveau d'exigence relativement élevé
donc vous avez parlé de solution
combinatoires pour limiter les usages
phyos aussi les jeunes agriculteurs ont
participé à un essai d'utilisation de
matériel robotisé sur une exploitation
donc la coopérative éméire donc légume a
utilisé un matériel tracté bourré de
capteur repérant les
Adventis de la taille d'un ongle donc
très petit afin de déposer une goutte
d'herbicide juste sur l'adventiste au
lieu de pulvériser sur 70 cm de large
comme cela se pratiquait jusqu'à
maintenant euh coût de la machine 6000
€. sachant que c'est une machine qui
avance tout doucement
euh comment est-ce que l'on peut
accompagner les agriculteurs dans ce
type d'investissement qui iront dans le
sens de la réduction des des produits
phyau euh sachant que bien évidemment si
on avance tout doucement ça coûte 600000
€ même si on le met en CUMA la question
c'est comment est-ce que l'on gère et
donc qu'est-ce qu'il est possible pour
vous de faire sur ce point-là donc ça
c'était pour la question de de de de
Nicole Nicole lepé pour ma part je je
souhaite revenir sur alors je vais me
limiter en nombre de points j'ai entendu
la demande à la fois du président et et
et du rapporteur donc comme vous avez
évoqué
laadosophile je vais passer sur la
punaise diabolique euh donc quand on
parle de
euh d'autorisation et de lutte contre
certains certains
parasites il peut exister des
solutions la question c'est pour quelle
raison sont-elles utilisées ou non
utilisées dans notre pays je pense
notamment sur alors si je reprends les
éléments concernant la punae diabolique
qui nous ont été mis à disposition par
l'association nationale pomme poire donc
l'existence d'insectes qui pourrait
lutter contre cette punèse diabolique
pour quelle raison aujourd'hui en France
on utilise pas ces techniques sachant
que c'est une demande des producteurs
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on y qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'on y va pas ou quels sont les
délais qui ferait qu'on pourrait y aller
parce que c'est vraiment une réponse
fortement attendue par les producteurs
parce que s'il existe réellement des
solutions euh il serait bien qu'on
puisse les utiliser mon mon deuxième
point concerne la réduction de l'usage
des phyos avec notamment le label le
label HVE qui dans ces quatre briques en
comprend une dédiée au phito mais qui va
bien évidemment au-delà sur d'autres
briques quel est votre avis quant à son
utilisation la nécessité de le
développer plus largement pour réduire
l'usage des produits phyos dans notre
pays je vous remercie merci chers
collèguees madame pochon merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre moi
aussi je vais je vais être courte dans
mes questions et surtout certaines ont
déjà été posées notamment concernant le
glyphosate vous dites ici les
interdictions ont des effets en matière
de souveraineté alimentaire TER nous
avons des exemples très concrets euh on
voit beaucoup de produits qui ne
souffrent pas d'interdiction mais qui
sont en grande difficulté qui et qui
posent en question effectivement sur la
souveraineté alimentaire également
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner des
exemples qui sont directement liés à une
interdiction et qui a mis en difficulté
une filière euh je pense pour ma part à
l'arrêt en 2017 du système de quota
appliqué au betav par exemple qui
garantissait des prix rémunérateurs aux
producteurs les cours de betterves ont
chuté les betterraviers ont alors
cherché à retrouver des marges en
maximisant les rendements à des niveaux
très él
ce qui n'est possible qu'avec les
néonicotinoïdes est-ce que sur un
exemple comme celui-ci on aurait pas pu
maintenir à la fois la souveraineté
alimentaire et des objectif sanitaire et
écologique la deuxième chose que vous
mentionnez c'est la nécessité
d'anticiper et d'accélérer finalement la
recherche en matière
d'alternative aux produits
phytosanitaires là moi je me réfère à ce
qui s'est passé ou ce qui se passe sur
le S méol chlore dont l'autorisation a
été prolongée jusqu'à novembre 2024 on
sait depuis 2004 avant la première
commercialisation des produits à base de
s
métholachlore la dangerosité de ces
produits du fait de la Commission
européenne qui alertait déjà les
États-membres sur le potentiel de
contamination des eaux souterraines par
ces principaux métabolites ces
difficultés finalement qui vont être
liées à l'utilisation de ce produit
elles sont tout à fait anticipables
elles sont tout à fait prévisibles on
sait déjà ce qu'il va advevenir on sait
les risques auxquels nous faisons face
et finalement vous parliez tout à
l'heure de quantification des
trajectoires comment est-ce que c'est
pas le rôle de la de est-ce que c'est
pas la responsabilité finalement de la
puissance publique justement d'anticiper
de savoir depuis 20 ans en ce qui
concerne le S mol la chlore les risque
que cela va engendrer et de repousser
tous les ans les les autorisations de
enfin les la possibilité en tout cas
d'interdire ces produits dont on sait
les effets néfastes on sait qu'on va y
aller faut il faut peut-être
effectivement anticiper pour tenir un
cap assez clair auprès des
agriculteurs 3ème question sur
l'obligation moyen
euh vous avez parlé des choix
budgétaires enfin plusieurs questions
ont porté là-dessus notamment sur la
question des MAEC des quelques dizaines
de millions d'euros qui sont investis
dans dans la transition effectivement et
dans dans le programme écofito au vu des
milliards de la PAC mais sur la question
du rapporteur euh vous nous avez dit que
les chiffres qui étaient donnés euh
était finalement sans base réelle on
pouvait pas quantifier exactement
combien de de millions avaient été
fléchés vers la transition dans les dans
les différents budgets je peux
l'admettre mais pourquoi moi ça je suis
assez étonné par le fait qu'on n pas
d'évaluation des investissements dans
dans dans l'agroécologie dans la
transition écologique en agriculture que
que votre ministère ne puisse pas
quantifier quels sont les financements
qui sont effectivement fléchés vers une
agriculture qui qui soit durable euh
donc c'est c'est vraiment ma question
est-ce qu'il y a un travail qui est fait
en ce moment même au sein du ministère
pour parce que c'est générement des des
chiffres qu'on souhaite mettre en avant
donc j'étais un petit peu étonné de la
réponse que vous avez faite à à Monsieur
le le rapporteur et je vais m'en arrêter
là je vous remercie merci chers
collègues monsieur le ministre il est
déjà 35 on va évidemment déborder sur le
temps pr siement éta à 40 donnons-nous
jusqu'à 55 il y a encore trois
commissaires qui auront des questions à
vous poser
madame pochon si j'étais taquin je vous
dirais la conditionnalité dans la PAC
c'est pour tout le monde je mets 7
milliards
ou 9 milliards voyez ce que je veux dire
la
conditionnalité la rotation enfin bref
l'interc la conditionnalité donc ce
qu'il faut quantifier donc faut faut
qu'on le fasse dans la pâack existante
mais c'est c'est un tout petit peu je
disais pas que Monsieur potier avait
raison tort je disais 600 pourquoi 600
et pourquoi pas 7 et pourquoi pas 100 et
milliards et pas 100 millions
euh quand vous faites un système qui
permet de plutôt favoriser le système
herbager vous le comptez comment vous
fait un ratio une part de de l'aide au
maintien de surface herbageère voyez je
veux dire c'est un peu plus et donc je
pense qu'il faut mieux se fixer des
objectifs en disant est-ce que ça
contribue bien à un objectifs
c'est-àdire qu'il faut pas qu'on ait une
pâack et pour le coup moi je pense
qu'elle est plutôt dans cette
trajectoire là qui vient de contrevenir
à des objectifs carbones à des objectifs
phyo à des objectifs biodiversité mais
après dire dans la mesure parce que la
mesure la mesure les mesures sur le E
sur la E ou les
mesures quelle est la part que j'affecte
aux objectifs de phyo la part que
j'affecte à la biodive et c'est un peu
compliqué me semble-t-il de le faire
comme ça deuxième je commence par vous
parce que j'ai commencé par la votre
dernière question oui c'est ce que
j'essaie de décrire sur la question de
l'anticipation c'est exactement ce qu'on
essaie de changer dans France de France
dans dans écopyo 2030 comme c'est
toujours 2030 à chaque fois c'est moi je
dis 2030 parce que 2030 ça veut dire
2030 c'est pas une addition
euh c'est exactement ça qu'il faut qu'on
fasse c'est-à-dire de dire on sait qu'on
on peut avoir des alertes sur par
ailleurs excusez-moi de vous dire les
décisions esméo la chlore qu'on se mette
d'accord la décision de l'an elle est
produite j'en sais quelques chose
puisque ça a fait l'objet d'une
controverse avec Monsieur potier la
décision de l'ANS enfin où on respecte
où on est je n'ai pas Lans à géométrie
variable ils ont pris une décision
éclairée au printemps ils ont dit des
choses ils ont dit on interdit l'fsa
par-dessus a dit on fait la même chose
euh venez pas nous reprocher de dire LAN
a été trop VO alà il faut qu'on vienne
challenger LAN tout le temps et à ce
momentl on va être dans un autre débat
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'anticiper c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce
travail en Task Force filière et cetera
pour dire ces molécules là posent des
interrogations sans qu'on ait encore la
réponse mais comme il y a des
interrogations essayons d'anticiper et
donc je partage votre sentiment et c'est
ça ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse vous dites
on met on met quelques moyens pardon 250
million d'Uros chaque
année en plus de ce qu'on met RPD les 70
millions j'ajoute que il y aura quand
même une question je dis au rapporteur
au président RPD c'est 180 millions il y
en a une partie nationale une partie
territoriale par les agences de l'eau il
faut qu'on regarde si tout ça converge
vers la trajectoire il n'est pas
illégitime que les agriculteurs se
disent et les 110 millions prélev les
autres ils servent quelle cause quand
même pas inintéressant en terme de de
moyen donc c'est pas quelques millions
hein sur c'est c'est il y a ce qu' ce
qu'il y a dans la PAC il y a en plus
quelque chose qui est ciblé sur la
question desfit après vous me dites
pardon je maintiens ce que j'ai dit il y
a parfois des interdictions sans
préparation sans anticipation qui créent
des problèmes de souvverineté parce que
la betterave aujourd'hui est très élevée
en tarif il y a quand même des gens
aujourd'hui donc vous pourriez dire
c'est ça qui est incitatif sur le modèle
de Skav les cotas sauf que les
betterviers je rendcontre des vrais
brviers des vrais gens ils me disent moi
si j'ai un risque jeunise pour perdre 40
% de ma récotte j'y vais pas parce qu'il
y a pas de modèle économique qui
tienneent si vous êtes soumis à quelque
chose chose de l'ordre je perds 40 % de
ma récolte tous les ans ou tous les 3
ans ça ne marche pas ça donc ça la Solle
baraavière elle a baiss elle a baissé
DEP de 10ieurs dizaines de milliers
d'hectares et quand vous interrogez les
béraviers c'est pas principalement les
prix ils savent qu'ils sont sur des prix
comme
ça historiquement le sucre a toujours
été comme ça c'est vrai que les quotas
bref c'est une vieille histoire les
quotas ça a été mais le sujet pas là le
sujet non mais le sujet n'est pas la
rémunération principalement le sujet
c'est l'impasse technique c'est quand
vous quand vous avez dans les
départements de quelques-uns qui sont
ici des gens qui perdent 80 % à couche
de la drosophile ça ne marche pas c'est
juste on va et après vous me poserez la
question de qui qui paye le consommateur
paye une le kilo de cerise à 50 € parce
qu'on a une récolte toute rabougerie ça
marche pas j'ajoute que si on a pas des
moyens de lutte qui peuvent être des
moyens de biocontrôle donc on a besoin
d'anticipation on va avoir des
fluctuations de prix inflation cette
année on a de l'inflation sur l'huile
d'olive sur les
oranges sur le sucre qui sont
principalement liés ou des impasses
techniques ou des ou du dérèglement
climatique donc il faut quand même qu'on
se préserve de ça un petit peu donc il
me semble que oui il y a des exemples
concrets j'en fais pas une généralité
vous m'avez pas entendu dire ça je pense
qu'on peut trouver des trajectoires où
on réduit et on garde notre souveraineté
notre compétitivité mais le mot
compétitivité ne me choque pas parce que
je veux dire il y a pas de modèle qui
tiennent en tout cas en économie non
classique pas hyper libéral si le gars
il perd de l'argent tous les ans il va
dire je vais faire une autre culture
c'est pas très compliqué en fait he
c'est normal d'ailleurs vous feriez nous
ferions vous et moi euh comme eux sur
sur sur cette sur cette question
euh madame le P a posé la question sur
euh euh robot oui c'est des outils qui
sont importants et c'est ce qu'on
finance en partie dans France 2030
hein et c'est plutôt la réussite de de
de de de cette disposition que d'essayer
d'encourager la robotique alors c'est
une des voies c'est pas la seule mais on
sait que c'est des outils sur ce type de
de de secteur c'est c'est entre 60 et 80
% de réduction des phyau si on avait une
solution de même nature partout on
aurait une trajectoire quel que soit
notre mode de calcul avec Monsieur
potier qui serait une trajectoire de
réduction il me semble que c'est un
élément important sur les affaires
punaise diabolique alors il y a des
affaires il y a beaucoup de fantasmes
aussi sur le thème j'ai vu quelqu'un qui
a vu quelqu'un qui a vu quelqu'un en
Italie qui lui a dit que la molécule est
alors après quand vous regardez c'est en
fait généralement pas tout à fait comme
ça parce que c'est un bouche à oreille
je sais pas si c'est un pour 7 mais
c'est peut-être même 7 pour un dans ces
cas-là attention dans la plupart des cas
on m'a saisi j'ai constaté qu'en fait la
molécule é interdite ou que le pays on
m'a saisi de cette question c'était pas
sur la punesse diabolique c'était sur
autre chose euh partout on regarde les
services de la DGL chaque année dans les
dérogations 120 jours on regarde il
compris on fait évoluer les les
stratégies pour essayer de trouver une
une alternative et quand le produit est
est autorisé euh la la la molécule est
autorisée au niveau européen après il y
a l'autorisation sur le mise sur marché
et qu'on peut activer des des dérogues
on les fait hein parce que il faut pas
mettre des gens en situation d'impasse
mais le jour m'a saisi on m'a dit oh là
là c'est un produit en Italie on a
vérifié il existe plus en Italie depuis
très longtemps on appelé les services
les équivalents des GAL là-bas bon il y
a beaucoup de fantasmes je parle pas des
gens qui fraudent mais je qui est un
autre registre ça peut
exister on regardera sur ce sujet
particulier mais je je demande un droit
d'inventaire si je peux dire sur cette
question là quant à la question du label
HVE bah le labelve il contribue
d'ailleurs on s'est fait un peu
reprocher ça fait partie alors je le
mets dans quel cas budgétaire on s fait
reprocher parfois par le monde agricole
d'avoir augmenté les exigences puisque
la voie par la voie économique a été é
supprimé qu'on a une voix plutôt par les
pratiques euh qui a été qui a été
importante et donc euh la certification
HVE c'est interdiction des produits
phyos en cmr1 bon euh elle valorise la
non utilisation des cmr2 euh elle
travaille sur la question des IFT même
s'il y a des biaets qui sont évoqués par
Monsieur de Fournas sur la question des
IFT je je je vois bien queon est en
train d'essayer de travailler cette
questionlà ça la belle HVE contribue
alors ça a été beaucoup vilipandé je
trouve que c'est une voie qui est une
voie d'amélioration des pratiques qui
est une voix intéressante c'est pas
c'est une voix de la transition donc il
faut pas se priver du label
HVE merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Martino merci monsieur le Président
merci bonjour monsieur le ministre et je
vous remercie pour votre présentation de
notre agriculture qui est bon de
rappeler que nous avons justement une
des meilleures au monde en préambule je
tiens à rappeler que je ne connais pas
d'agriculteurs qui utilisent des
produits phyos par plaisir j'ai aimé
lorsque vous avez parlé de juste de
reconception des modèles sûrement mais
le défi d'entraînement ne marche pas à
tous les coups et je citerai en exemple
une organisation de producteur que je
connais très bien puisque j'en fais
partie avec trois producteurs qui se
sont convertis en bio euh il y a
quelques années sur 12 ce qui est quand
même un/4 mais seulement de
consommateurs et d'acheteurs certains se
retournent et retournent vers le
conventionnel alors produire bio ce
n'est pas sans traitement c'est plus de
travail manuel ce sont des impasses
techniques et des pertes des
déclassements personnellement j'ai
arraché la moitié de mon verger et la
quasi-totalité de mes sisiers en
quelques années parce que justement on a
des impasses il faut changer les
variétés ça se fait pas si facilement
les producteurs produisent ce qui se
vend et la majorité des consommateurs
vont vers les promotions alors
reconcevoir les modèles selon moi
n'est-ce pas l'éducation déjà des
consommateurs des acheteurs accepter des
fruits et légumes moches oui on voit
bien que ça ne se vend pas subir les
cahers des charges des grands magasins
est-il raisonnable d'exiger aux
agriculteurs des fruits d'apparence
impeccable et sans pesticides en clair
les Français sont-ils prêts à
reconcevoir ce modèle économique payer
le prix juste une nourriture d'aspects
différentes je m'interroge et je vous
pose la question je vous remercie merci
chers collègues monsieur
fugit merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre beaucoup de choses
ont été évoquées je sais que le temps
presse quand prend le temps d'évoquer
quelques points parce que quand même la
chance de vous avoir ici avec nous euh
moi je voulais revenir sur quelques
sujet notamment entre autres le sujet de
la formation et de la recherche et puis
aussi éventuellement avoir votre retour
sur comment vous vous vous concevez vous
la relation entre les agriculteurs et
instituts de recherche ou les agences
puisque votre prédécesseur hier nous
disait qu'il avait constaté parfois
qu'il y avait de la défiance qui s'était
installée il le déplorait bien entendu
et donc c'est c'est intéressant pour
nous d'avoir aussi votre vision à vous
tout simplement et puis j'en profite
pour au travers la recherche et
l'innovation vous interroger sur comment
vous voyez l'avenir de l'agriculture
notamment à travers toutes les
innovations que ce soit d'intelligence
artificielle robotique et cetera est-ce
que c'est moyens du futur c'est vous y
croyez au point que on pourrait penser
que on pourrait envisager peut-être
d'avoir un effort de guerre sur ce sujet
d'un point de vue financier pour
peut-être aller plus vite donc dans les
transitions qui qui nous intéressent un
autre point c'est sur la question des
des des clauses miroires je sais bien
qu'elles sont pas applicables au sein de
de de l'UE mais finalement au fond
est-ce que ça serait pas souhaitable
est-ce que ce serait pas souhaitable je
c'est une question peut-être que c'est
une question bête que je vous pose mais
je voulais quand même la poser est-ce
que ce serait pas souhaitable et et si
oui comment faire et puis moi je vous
poser une autre question question qui
est un peu provocatrice c'est y y a-t-il
un pays qui est qui pour vous est est
inspirant est-ce qu'il y a un pays qu'il
faut suivre dans sa manière de faire
donc de en matière de agricole et enfit
je voudrais revenir sur le la question
du glyphosate pour deux raisons dans la
deè deuxème est évidemment une raison
d'actualité très chaude la première
c'est tout à l'heure on a évoqué un
petit peu les les bilans les notamment
les les problématiques de planification
écologique quand vous avez travaé sur la
planification écologique vous travaillez
sur faire en sorte de trouver des
leviers pour diminuer les émissions de
CO2 lié à l'agriculture comme l' le
demande pour les autres secteurs le
transport l'industrie le logement et
cetera et si je prends par exemple le
cas de l'agriculture de conservation des
sols l'agriculture de conservation des
sols j'en ai beaucoup parlé dans le
rapport glyphosate donc j'invite
d'ailleurs la collègue qui parlé tout à
l'heure de savoir comment-ce que s'était
passé entre 18 2018- 2023 je vous invite
à lire le le rapport de la mission
parlementaire de 2020 je pense
sincèrement que pendant 2 ans on a bien
décrit ce qui se passait
et si vous si vous raisonnez en
agriculture de conservation des sa ben
vous allez avoir une agriculture qui va
émettre tro fois moins de CO2 donc c'est
plutôt bien pour la planification
écologique qui consiste à diminuer le
poids non parce qu'on la Bour plus on la
Bour en tout cas on travaille beaucoup
moins le sol le sol est mieux un pe
diversité et cetera et CEA sauf que
l'agriculture conservation des sols on
l'a expliqué dans le rapport en 2020
André chass il nous disait hier que ses
agriculteurs lui avaient expliqué et il
nous l'explique à tous régulièrement et
ben ça nécessite bien souvent un petit
coup de glyphosate à un moment donné
voilà et quand on fait le bilan global
pourtant c'est vertueux en terme
deersité faites-le moi j'ai bêché
moi-même plusieurs sols en conventionnel
en bio et en agriculture conservation
des sols je l'affirme la conservation
des sols c'est même mieux que
l'agriculture biologique pour le sol oui
je sais que c'est un peu long monsieur
le Président mais j'ai quand même une
question d'actualité importante c'est
sur le glyphosate justement ce matin il
y a eu le vote et l'Europe l'Union
européenne ne s'est pas mis d'accord sur
le les 27 pays ne sont pas mis d'accord
pour la réautorisation du du glyphosate
je voulais avoir évidemment la réaction
du du ministre d'agriculture ici en
direct et il semblerait que maintenant
ce soit la Commission européenne qui
tranche et et donc je voulais voir
savoir un petit peu comment vous voyez
les choses donc sur ce sujet et j'en
profite aussi pour vous renouveler
l'invitation à venir rencontrer la
coopérative qui réunit 150 producteurs
arbriculteurs dans ma circonscription et
un verger exploratoire très intéressant
justement lié à tous ces problèmes là
dont on parle pour réduire les produits
phyos excusez-moi c'est un petit pe long
monsieur le Président mais c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on a la chance d'avoir
un ministre d'agriculture et puis je
pense pas avoir un plus dit des
bêtises merci chers collègue dernière
intervention président chassigne ensuite
monsieur le MIN je vous demanderai de
répondre en en
concluant dernières interventions
d'abord deux observations la première
sur les sur le
HVE le constat que l'on fait c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est exploité pour
dévaloriser le bio je crois que c'est
une réalité on regarde critères j'ai on
m'a cité un exemple on m'a cité un
exemple où la filière
Carrefour exige des producteurs bio en
plus en plus de reconnaissance bio la
certification HVE enfin c'est quelque
chose quand même incroyable c'est quand
même quelque chose d'incroyable première
observation deuxème observation on est
tous d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut une
transition écologiqueexloitation on est
tous d'accord sur fait qu'il faut la
nécessité de transformer les modes de
production le problème ça a été dit et
pour ça je passerai rapid rapidement
dessus il faut les Levi et est-ce que
les leviers on les a véritablement
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs même s'ils
ont conscience ils ont conscience de
cette exigence de la transition
écologique et de se passer de pesticides
et ben il faut qu'ils puissent avoir
leur revenus or contement à ce que vous
avez dit Monsieur le Ministre les
écoorégimes aujourd'hui et ça c'est des
témoignages que l'on a de chercheurs que
l'on a d'organisations agricooles les
écoorégimes aujourd'hui ne créent pas le
levier suffisant pour passer du niveau 1
au niveau 2 et il y a la quasi totalité
donc des agriculteurs de notre pays qui
sont au niveau 1 mais l'objectif c'est
pas seulement qui est le niveau 1 c'est
de passer à un niveau supérieur et on
nous dit que ce levier n'existe pas
deuxièmement sur les MAEC je reviens pas
dessus mais enfin enfin des des
producteurs qui sont qui ont investi
pour transformer leur mode leur mode de
production à qui on j on dit aujourd'hui
on n pas l'argent pour répondre au
niveau alors ce qui le gros problème que
vous avez je le comprends je su pas là
en donneur de leçon c'est que vous êtes
sur une politique budgétaire de vase
communiquant de vase communiquant d'un
côté avec les écorégime on veut pas
toucher à la grande masse parce qu'il y
a des il y a derrière des pressions
c'est comment ça fonctionne dans ce pays
je veux pas vous faire de dessin et en
ce qui concerne en ce qui concerne les
Maek c'est les vases communiquants avec
les agences de l'eau si j'ai bien
compris et donc là il y a il y a un vrai
problème qui se pose je termine avecune
question après ces observations je me
pose quand même la question des de
l'usage des pesticides aussi je crois
qu'on on niniste pas suffisamment
là-dessus sur l'usage des pesticides il
y a les les chefs d'exploitation qui ont
fait des formations on m'a cité le cas
de travailleurs d'ouvriers agricoes soit
des pas les ouvriers agricoles qui ent
qui sont dans les entreprises de travaux
agricoles parce que les formations se
font mais les ouvriers agricoles qui
sont embauchés directement ou par les
les agences d'intérim cet espèce de
mafia qui existe aujourd'hui quelquefois
hein pour fournir des ouvriers agricoles
au niveau de de de certaines productions
et ben on fait utiliser des pesticides à
des gens qui ne sont pas formés et ça
c'est pas
normal merci monsieur le Président monie
ministre monsieur le rapporteur je vais
essayer de faire court alors Monsieur
martinau euh oui la question il c'est
c'est une très bonne question parce
qu'en fait est-ce que le levier
alimentation est un levier de
transformation de l'agriculture c'est ça
en fait la question que vous poser
est-ce que par l'alimentation on
encourage un modèle d'agriculture qui
nous paraît utile pour les agriculteurs
parce qu'il faut penser à eux est utile
pour la société d'un point de vue
général alors c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites les fruits ce
qu'on appelle les fruits moches
euh aujourd'hui ne joue ne sont pas mis
en valeur ou sont dévalorisés que le
chemin n'est pas à trouver là-dessus
enfin je vais vous dire pardon je veux
pas m'acharné hein parce que vous allez
croire que c'est ça tourne je tourne en
rond comme dans le hamster dans sa dans
sa roue mais c'est la responsabilité de
la grande distribution aussi c'estd
qu'il faut que collectivement on dise
c'est le bio quand ça allait bien il y
en avait plein les étal qu'on avait une
croissance à 10 % il c'était rempli
partout le bio le bio le bio le bio très
bien ça les gens ont cru que les armes
montaient jusqu'au ciel ce qui n'est pas
une réalité même
économique au-delà d'une réalité
photosynthèse et on se retrouve
maintenant avec la grand distrip le
marché se rétracte et donc il y a un
demir-rang caché dans un coin et comme
ça on est sûr que on continue le
maltusianisme de la consommation du bio
donc il y a quand même une
responsabilité le gaspillage qui est
produit dans ce cadre là une partie du
gaspillage alimentaire et compris
carbone est un gaspillage de calibrage
où c'est moche ça part à la poubelle on
est quand même chez les fous dans un
monde où les gens ont pas les moyens et
o on nous explique toute la journée
qu'il faut euh utiliser au mieux les
facteurs de production oui donc mais ça
c'est un travail qu'on doit faire et
compris dans la stratégie alimentation
plutôt je vais vous le dire que de se
poser la question de c'est est-ce qu'il
faut un régime végétarien par semaine je
pense qu'on ferait mieux de se poser la
question de comment on fait en sorte
qu'on ait pas toutes ces pertes de
produits agricoles parce que la grande
distrip joue sur ce tru-là et et casse
le prix du Gar ou le dos du Gap en
disant ah il est pas calibré comme il
faut tu peux le renvoyer euh et je te
perai jamais puisque de toute façon
c'était pas calibré comme il fallait oui
il y a un problème oui et donc ça c'est
un élément dans la stratégie
alimentation qu'on devrait pousser y
compris sur les question carbone et phyo
il y a ça ça ça sera peut-être plus
utile que des débats qu'on a depuis 25
ans qui n nous mèneent à rien monsieur
fugit je sais qu'en plus vous êtes très
engagé j'ai un j'ai bien
votreenouvellement d'invitation et comme
vous le savez j'essaierai de tenir mon
engagement parce que ça fait trop
longtemps que je le je fais sans le
tenir formation recherche oui c'est un
élément vous avez raison et Julien de
Normandie a raison d'évoquer la question
d'un comment dirais-je d'une disjonction
et parfois une espèce de de de mauvais
débat qui est fait oui la recherche
fondamentale en fait ils sont pas dans
les pieds dans la c'est pas dans les
fermes leur trucs c'est dans des dans
des éprouvettes ça marche pas ce qui est
inexact d'abord et on nous avons avec
tinra sans toutoute l'Institut le plus
puissant du monde et avec le CAD aussi
d'ailleurs parce que ils ont aussi des
choses à dire le plus puissant du monde
en terme de recherche et d'innovation et
après moi je vois ce qu'on a fait sur le
pnri avec les des directeurs de de
recherche de liineraay et les instituts
techniques l'Institut de la betterave
pour le coup il faut qu'on pense
toujours là ce que vous avez évoqué tous
les deux c'est comment on massifie
c'estd à chaque fois comment je
reconceptualise le et il y a des freins
parfois économiques le modèle se tient
pas et de de j'ai toujours fait comme ça
et le toujours fait comme j'ai fait
comme ça c'est comme nous hein
d'ailleurs on a toujours fait comme ça
bon on a toujours une voiture à moteur à
explosion bon très bien pour en changer
ok euh donc c'est c'est exactement
là-dessus qu'il faut jouer c'est là
qu'on a besoin la recherche fondamentale
de la recherche appliquée et des
questions de massification agrirobotique
oui bien sûr qu'on a besoin de ces
outilslà j'ai a répondu tout à l'heure
au travers de la question qui était
posée j' ajoute un dernier élément parce
que ça va être un débat européen euh
faut pas se priver des NBT et des NGT
hein une partie de la résistance des
plante elle va se tenir là parce qu'on
peut pas dire pas de phyo zéro phyo 0
NBT 0 NGT z0ro zéro rien bah à la fin il
poussera rien on va pas on va pas se
raconter d'histoire enfin moi je sais
pas j'ai un jardin si j'ai rien de rien
j'aurai rien hein ça donc je mais je
mets NBT à ce moment-là parce que je
pense que c'est un élément important
close miroir là je suis radicalement
désaccord avec vous si on commence à
dire je fais ma clause miroir il y a
c'est fini
Europe non mais je vous le dis c'est
c'est comment qu'est-ce que a dit le
président chassen comme méchanceté j'ai
ça serait la Renaissance ça serait ah
c'est bon je vois vous étiez malicieux
dans votre interpellation oui mais je
vais vous dire on a besoin alors moi je
suis pas à penser qu'il faut faire et
c'est des débats que j'ai d'ailleurs
parfois avec Monsieur chassen et
d'autres ici dans cette salle qu'il faut
faire que des échanges internationaux
l'ultra l'ultra échange mais dans le
modèle de dérèglement climatique dans
lequel on est on va avoir intérêt à
avoir des coopérations entre Européens
et même au-delà de l'Europe hein cette
année on peut pas couvrir les besoins
ené dur et voir tendre d'une partie de
l'Europe en Italie et en Espagne he
c'est le dérèglement climatique hein
donc faut quand même qu'on se donc ne
nous mettons pas trop d'entrave y
compris sur la question de la production
et et de la souveraineté évidemment
c'est un élément important euh le péri
inspirant sur le modèle agricole enfin
j'aurais tendance à à dire non pas pour
faire plaisir mais je je sais pas quel
pays fait mieux que
nous donc c'est je m'inspire du modèle
français et il faut il faut le dire aux
agriculteurs aussi parce que c'est assez
déplorable de voir les débats qu'on a
chez nous quand je parle avec mes autres
collègues ils sont fascinés de voir les
débats qu'on a chez nous hein parce
qu'il nous regardent en disant mais
pourtant vous êtes très avancé hein sur
des tas de sujets et il y a un moment la
corde rond avec le monde agricole à
cause de ça faut arrêter de dénigrer ça
veut pas dire que ne pas dénigrer ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des démarche
de progrès et des pas des encouragements
à la transition mais quand vous passez
votre temps à dire les produits sont
mauvais même le bu vous a des reportages
pour dire c'est affreux on a mis des
produits bah oui le bio met des produits
oui oui c'est pas POS pas et puis c'est
des produits qui sont parfois toxiques
même même s'ils sont naturels quand ils
sont à haute dose comme le reste bon
donc faut qu'on apprenne tout ça
collectivement et le modèle inspirant
pour moi est un modèle français sous
réserve que il est soiviable
économiquement sinon il sera pas
inspirant il sera juste comment
dirais-je un arat de modèle inspirant
quant au
glyphosate c'est bien pour ça que la
position française a été celle-là euh la
Commission européenne vient de d'un
suite au vote qui a été le forme à ce
qui avait été la dernière fois vient de
dire qu'elle réautorisé sur 10 ans dans
les conditions qui sont les ciels nous
nous continuerons à trouver notre
trajectoire au travers des efforts qui
ont été faits on va pas revenir en
arrière sur le sujet mais la décision
est tombée là donc je je peux vous
répondre là-dessus et vous avez raison
je n'est personne qui peut me dire ce
qu'on fait pour l'agriculture de
conservation des sols dont on sait quand
on regarde que c'est une agriculture qui
porte plein
d'avantage en terme de stockage du
carbone de stockage de l'eau de qualité
des sols de lutte contre on a des sols
qui ont été très usés qui par
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
ça veut pas dire qu'un jour on trouvera
pas une alternative je disais hier sur
France Info quelqu'un me disait
journaliste me disait ah ça fait 6 ans
que vous cherchez vous avez pas trouvé
oui ça fait parfois 100 ans qu'on
cherche sur des maladies on a pas trouvé
hein ENF faut être modeste aussi dans la
vie oui c'est compliqué l'agriculture de
conservation des sols je reconnais je
suis pas un scientifique ni un chercheur
de Line r d'institut technique je vois
pas l'alternative or c'est utile dans la
reconception y compris du modèle parce
que c'est une reconception une pensée
aussi sur la question du matériel c'est
pas du tout la même chose dans la façon
don travail et on sait à quel point le
travail trop profond du sol est
compliqué monsieur
chassigne je vous ai repéré euh non bio
HVE je je là aussi c'est un sujet grand
distrip enfin moi j'ai il m'arrive
encore de faire des courses quand je
veux du bio je veux du bio et je me dis
pas où est le truc HVE hein non c'est
pas un acte de consommateur c'est un
acte de la grande distribution donc
c'est là qu'on a un problème donc c'est
là qu'il faut qu'on en parle avec eux
mais c'est pas un acte de consommateur
ENF je croisez pas des gens dans les
rayons où est le rayon
HVE parce que ça existe pas en fait
attention non après c'est dans les
critères que donne la grande
distribution il disent ça donc c'est un
élément évidemment sur lequel il faut
être vigilant mais ça je trouve que
c'est toujours une erreur de penser que
en dévalorisant les autres les autres
critères type HVE on va on va gagner ses
parts de marché je pense que le bio à sa
place et le HVE est autre chose dans une
tradicoire j'ajoute par ailleurs pour
être très précis sur la question de les
écorégimes il y a plus d'agriculteurs
aujourd'hui en niveau 2 qu'en niveau 1
je ben oui pardon dans dans les
remontées qu'on a de déclaration pack on
a a plus en deux quand un et ouais et
tant mieux et on a 94 % des des on a 94
% des agriculteurs français qui sont
rentrés dans le dispositif écorégime ce
qui pose des problèmes de régulation
d'ailleurs quand les Allemands qui ont
choisi autre chose je leur fait pas
grief ils en ont que 60 % donc ils ont
des problèmes y compris de budgétaire
bon c'est parce que je trouve que
l'intérêt de l'écoorégime c'est qu'il
fait prendre chez marche chacun prend sa
marche et certains peuvent aller en un
et puis d'autres vont en deux tout de
suite la preuve en est et puis les un
faudra les encourager après à aller au
niveau 2 il me semble que c'est un un
élément important et puis j'ai bien noté
enfin oui il y a une question de
formation des usages c'est d'ailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs le cas dans les usages
de de phyo en agriculture comme ailleurs
dans les communes aussi vous savez ça
aussi bien que moi il faut qu'on forme
les gens et on sait qu'on a parfois
alors des fois l'employeur qui fait pas
attention et puis parfois le salarié
lui-même qui dit ça m'emmerde vos tenu
pardon du mot vos tenu vos masques
machin et donc il faut qu'on porte une
exigence en particulier sur les ouvriers
qui sont pas à à tenir dans les
exploitations c'est pas une question de
d'opérateur je pense que c'est une
question de quand vous es vous avez des
gens qui viennent que pour un mois pour
faire tel ou tel travaux c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin de formation et je en
tout cas je prends le point sur cette
sur cette question là voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire Monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur et mesdames et
messieurs les députés mais il nous reste
à à vous remercier monsieur le ministre
je crois que monsieur le rapporteur vous
direa un dernier mot merci beaucoup pour
le temps que vous avez pris pour votre
engagement pour la précision de vos
réponses je signale tout de suite le
rapporteur va conclure cette cette
audition je signale tout de suite au
commissaire que nous enchaînons la i
suivante avec Monsieur Stéphane
Lefol oh
pardon je voulais vous remercier
également pour la qualité du dialogue
que nous avons eu c'est pas c'est pas
une surprise nous auri aimé le prolonger
juste je me permets c'est pour mémoire
la question de du pilotage global et des
circuits financiers nous paraît pas du
tout adapté le le système de collecte de
la RPD de distribution et tout enfin
c'est une usine à gaz on va essayer de
faire une reconception pas seulement des
systèmes agricoles mais de de suggérer
des reconceptions des cofitau c'est
toujours c'est voilà c'est toujours
difficile pour les institutions de se
remettre en cause mais nous allons avoir
une certaine audace qui peut-être pourra
vous aider à prendre les bonnes
décisions je me permet en écho à ce
qu'on dit à la fois Marie pochon et
André chassigne de faire deux
suggestions mais très simples qui sont à
votre portée pour soutenir la bio qui
aujourd'hui a bien besoin de signaux
positifs deux microujets vous n'aurez
pas Deo de possibilité de répondre mais
je profite de l'enregistrement et de la
séance publique c'est pas possible qu'on
demande à un paysan bio pour entrer dans
un supermarché en plus de payer une
certification HVE il y a en terme de
critérisation on est sur quelque chose
de tellement mince et tellement
exceptionnel en terme de différenciation
des critères que franchement une mesure
de simplification heureuse pourrait au
moins considérer d' par qu'il faut
réformer HVE ça j'en suis militant il
faut aller plus loin dans HVE et cetera
mais que par ailleurs les bios sont
automatiquement HVE par ailleurs les B
VI souffre aujourd'hui à cause du Pr
folcarp vous le savez de de détour de de
perte de récolte qui ne sont pas
couvertes et qui pourraient l'être par
les systèmes de de sécurisation globale
c'est des sujets très simples hein c'est
les phyos aujourd'hui viennent polluer
des récoltes bio qui sont déclassées et
il y a pas d'assurance pour ça parce
qu'il y a pas de responsabilité civile
engageable pas vu la volatilité du du
produit c'est un problème qu'on peut pas
ignorer il doit être couvert par les
fonds de garantie
existant à dooc où on doit créer un fond
machin mais on peut pas rajouter ces
peines là à la bio à minima on compte
sur vous monsieur le ministre merci
c'est prévu dans ecopyo ce deuxième
point et pour le premier je pas le
soleil de Monsieur descosaill ça c'est
la relation commerciale est-ce que vous
pouvez empêcher une entreprise de dire
moi je veux tel critère mais je je
partage le point de vue que vous avez
évoqué tous les deux
hein